the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
to its name at the Superbad rapid and
Blitz in beautiful Warsaw Poland
fast-paced exciting games made the day
fly by for crowds of adoring fans
co-leaders faced off in the final round
for a shot to take the top spot in the
standings Wesley so had chances to claim
unquestioned first but the Polish Phenom
was able to escape with the draw and
maintain the status quo it looks like a
two-horse race going into the final day
of Rapid with several contenders in Hot
Pursuit
will they be able to catch the leaders
day three of action-packed chess
coming up next
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everybody to day three of
the 2023 Superbad rapid and Blitz held
here in Warsaw Poland we start the day
in front of the Tomb of the Unknown
Soldier which symbolizes the soldiers
that made the ultimate sacrifice for
Poland today is the final day of Rapid
chess we're going to see a lot of
valiant heroics on the chessboard let's
go to the studio and start the action
we welcome you to the second step on the
2023 granchester and our coverage of
Superbad pollen we come to you live from
the San Luis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone thanks for
joining us I'm International Master
nazify kids and I'm here with
Grandmaster yeah
as always a pleasure to be with you in
studio it's threatening to become the
Wesley so and Yan Duda show I know those
guys are doing amazing they sure are
hello everyone and thank you for joining
us and sharing your day
I tell you quite the contrast between
day one of the rapid and day two day one
features sixty percent decisive games
whereas yesterday day two the players
really Drew in their horn no more risk
taking and shut things down only at 20
percent uh uh number of decisive games
uh day two what will day three be bring
well we'll see in the meanwhile tell us
our standings next season all right
let's take a look we have two liters
Wesley soy and Jan Gustav Duda and in
clear third we have levonne Iranian
closely following Maxima Sheila Graf
with 50 Richard rapper and radoslavoy
tashek
and Magnus Carlson's still with minus
one I tell you that looks like a typo
something is wrong there and he hasn't
gotten a win yet
we have bugtong Daniel dick who had a
good day yesterday and recovered from
the first day and the last place sharing
we have Carol shevchenko and Anish giri
remind everybody of our format please
we have a 10 player round robin
tournament and in the rapid section the
time control is 25 minutes with 10
second increment in Blitz we will have 5
minutes with 2 second increment in Rapid
there's a non-traditional scoring system
two points for win one for a draw and
zero for loss however in Blitz we'll go
back to the traditional scoring system
with 1.4 win and half for a drop and no
draw offers at all and a remaining
schedule
we have a last day of rapid and two days
of Blitz coming up so today we will have
round seven eight and nine nice and as
always we're very happy to have in
studio version for what days we've been
having topsy-turvy what about our
undefeated players though absolutely yes
sir it's been a very interesting
tournament so far we had a lot of drones
yesterday but we have a lot of
undefeated players so far in this
tournament let's take a look
so we have mvl Who had who has a lot of
draws five draws and one win so it's
right now on a fourth place
Le bonaronian who had a great start in
the first day won two games and then
made four draws so far so it's a clear
third position right now
and do that we had an excellent first
day he started with two wins and then
made few draws and won around the fifth
game and currently typher first with
Wesley
and of course Wesley saw who had a very
interesting he had a win and a draw win
and a draw so he's got three wins and
three draws so far so we have critical
three rapid games remaining against six
points up for grabs so it's very
interesting to see and also if Magnus
can win a game and we're gonna go to
Poland to our friends Anastasia and
Christian
thanks VAR and welcome back chess fans
to the championship day here in Warsaw
Poland in the rapid section and what an
event we've had so far one player of
course that I'm having and everybody
else has been having their eyes on is of
course the former world champion Magnus
Carlson I didn't know what he will be
bringing to the table he started off
slowly in day one difficult defeat in
the Polish in Poland against the Polish
avoida check that was well a gamble
let's uh call it as it is it did not pay
off and unfortunately for him since then
he was unable to win a single game
nevertheless he is getting close and I
have to say today in the last three
rounds of the rapid portion he has great
chances to potentially score some
important victories because today is
Magnus Carlson versus Romania he's
playing all three Romanian players in
this event he's going to start with uh
the game with the black pieces against
Bogdan Daniel Daya who is struggle
building sure he had a better second day
but in the first day he lost all his
games so definitely Magnus with black
pieces will be trying to pose some
problems in round 8 kiril chefchenko
also struggling tied for Less with three
points and in round nine a player that
sure it's never easy to play against and
that is Richie report Richie has had
such amazing topsy-turvy games in this
tournament so definitely my eyes are
still on Magnus Carlsen I think he will
be able to potentially Mount The
Comeback and go into the blitz section
maybe not tied with the leaders but
close enough to the leaders Anastasia
we've actually seen Magnus before we got
to the plane hole tell us a bit about
that exactly today actually we saw
Magnus because we know that the weather
is so great and worse when he decided to
have a walk to the plane Hall he does it
every day and imagine what happened at
this moment the chess fan was just
passing by the street and then he saw
Magnus and he was so shocked and he
immediately decided it's his moment he's
to take the selfie and he did it and
then we managed to catch him and we had
the cup we exchanged some words he's
from Ukraine he came all this way uh to
Poland actually to meet to see Magnus
Carlson himself and then he just you
know he just met him like this on the
street and he was so happy and he
couldn't just speak I mean he showed the
photo here you see yes I mean what a
lucky day yes
and and actually when I turned the
camera I saw Magnus was also smiling I
think he's in a great mood today and I
think he's like you know ready to fight
it's a day number three now or never
right he should really try to push his
luck today in order to get so important
points in Rapid chest no absolutely and
I have to say he's been happy since the
beginning of the tournament you were
mentioning he's smiling he's listening
to his podcasts potentially we know that
this is uh his usual routine but he did
lose some routines in this tournament
he's not here with his family he's not
here with his coach he's here maybe for
the first time in his career by himself
exactly yes and he has some routine
between the games he goes down to have
some fresh air and we know that
yesterday he was even locked you know
outside but then he found his way to the
museum it was again some Journey but so
far so good we're looking forward to the
day number three absolutely and we will
be here to give you guys all the
insights from Warsaw Poland back to
University thank you Christian and
Anastasia I must say chest fever hits
Warsaw how cool is that uh lay the table
for our viewers and tell them what they
can expect for round seven coming up
soon let's take a look we have MPL
playing Wesley saw wow Marquee matchup
right there Iranian playing Muay tashek
it's so important important game and
then our leader do that playing
chefchenko giri against Robert India
against Carlson okay Magnus it's time to
shift gears here and they're going to be
lots of Fighting Chess today what are
they fighting for they're fighting for a
handsome price fund the first place
winner is going to win forty thousand
dollars nice second place thirty
thousand Thirty twenty five thousand a
total price fund of 175 000 all the way
down to 10th Place seven thousand
dollars Grand chess tour points up for
grabs if you win clear first you get a
bonus you get 13 Grand Chester points if
you share first well you'll be dividing
12.
um at the end of the tour the player
with the most grandchild store points
picks up a hundred thousand dollar uh
bonus very very useful as the players
get ready for round seven again this is
the last day of Rapids and tomorrow
they're moving uh to the blitz uh VAR
what's your expectation for this
important round for MBL and Wesley so I
think it's a critical game and if mvl
somehow can try to win this game he'll
be back in the race to try to catch
Wesleyan do that before the blitz
portion I I think for Magnus it's
extremely important try to score maybe a
two wins and a draw to get back into the
mix because if the Gap is too big before
they go to Bliss tournament it's going
to be very very hard to catch the
leaders exactly as we've seen lavono
Rodney and coming on stage wearing kind
of a multi-colored jacket would you
describe that Nancy what's going on
there
I like it he's always colorful exactly
the red collar
stands out
as Lavon takes his seat not sure who's
making the opening ceremonial first
moves but we've had quite uh an
assortment of the guests
big crowd for a weekday again no
question about it
Aaron Warsaw it looks very very well
attended it is always nice I seriously I
I loved it as a player when there was a
Restless audience
and there's the Marquee matchup we've
been talking about MBL uh on the left
the Frenchman versus hurricane Wesley so
Wesley has been
um I want to say dominant in some ways
he he's what we call 50
he's won three and drawn three that's
fifty percent no losses but he could
have more points he could have beaten
Duda and really separated himself Anish
having
not playing badly but oh thank God no it
did when it rained it's important but
today he can really spoil some Players
tournament because he's playing all the
leaders today including Richie by the
way Richie also very
um self-critical uh as he has been
spoiling some winning positions and he
almost has that look of like what am I
doing I let MBL Escape yeah yesterday he
said in the interview that anyone could
have won this position but me
it takes a talent sometimes a snatching
defeat from the jaws of Victory right
VAR I mean haven't we all you know
spoiled easy wins absolutely uh Richie
is not happy he's still probably
thinking about that game against nvl and
all the missed opportunities he had so
far right but it's important just to
forget about it when you start a new
game and try to do your best and there
we have it Daniel world's number one man
Agnes Carlson
coming on stage no jacket no walking
billboard as I would say but he is ready
to fight today exactly
uh very impressive what he did against
MBL he had absolutely absolutely nothing
and he kept working working working
and he nearly pulled it out I mean maybe
at one point the computer the table base
even gave him the win almost impossible
and practical and I saw the social media
post from granchester later Gary Magnus
and mvl were analyzing the two night end
game yeah and
there were some discussion is it winning
how do I win right Gary was telling
Magnus that he had a win yeah that he's
in the winning Zone yeah uh check that
out that uh two nights versus Pawn
ending uh
as the players are taking the seat and
again this is
yeah and just to remind everybody what
Farr said so the old Romanian uh lineup
today the uh uh yeah
okay uh yesterday we took a poll and
asked our viewers what they thought the
number of wins might be for Magnum
Sunset 3-0 Sunset two didn't get any I
mean he's still looking for that elusive
first Victory and the game's underway
French defense for E6 may be inspired a
little bit by Richard Rapport because
Richie
um is getting gained he's doing it
successfully yes yeah he's getting play
in the winner word uh uh especially I
think he maybe noticed that Magnus
played he's six years looking at it yeah
look uh oh a philodor uh very very
creative uh there
yeah so we have one Sicilian between
livon and uh not getting maybe I have
the wrong games uh yes you have it's
delayed for use oops I
but we can see on the screen we have
Bishop G5 French okay so the McCutchen
Bishop B4 and E5
uh that was actually a game
uh of a variation I used to analyze it
as a teenager I thought it was really
exciting age six whoa
now this implies upon sacrifice VAR I
capture on F6 and is this
is this uh
is this Pawn sacrifice for real
uh there are some games played with this
of course again Magnus is avoiding the
main tier like you mentioned Bishop
before is the maketron you could have
played D takes E4 there go to the
Ruben's time variation uh yeah this is
upon sacrifice here and let's take a
look uh how the theory usually develops
after this so quintess F6 is necessary
because you take back with the pawn uh
after taking on D5 and you're gonna have
a really bad structure here so this is a
really really bad position here so you
can go there yeah you have to take back
with the queen right which has happened
by the way he takes D5 and here's the
main move in this position there's only
the move Bishop B4 actually to try to
create some Contra play you're you're
going to be down upon and here white has
few options Bishop B5 is the main move
here D takes C6 is another possible
there is a game between cardiacin and
one Forest so Bishop B5 check now is
that Jordan or Lucas distinguished
Jordan okay and here's uh black and play
Bishop D7 okay Bishop D7
Knight D7
D takes E6
and queen takes E6 so it's it's upon
sacrifice where you try to capture on C3
and try to set up a blockade here and a
little bit better for white but not a
huge advantage or anything so I think
there's some chances here for black wow
not a huge Advantage Because by the way
the move H6 forces Bishop takes F6 I
mean now it's one of those things where
really white has no choice because after
Bishop H4
G5 Bishop to G3 either Knight takes or
simply Pawn tags and I'm not a fan of
White's uh Gambit so Bishop takes F6
Queen takes F6 takes Bishop B4 on the
board not Bishop B5 check which I
thought made a lot of sense Bishop C4
um I don't find myself attracted to this
move actually I think after castles the
chances of for decent compensation
actually just went up yeah I mean
our King is kind of feeling the heat a
little bit still remaining in the center
that's exactly what Magnus wants type of
position where he can well at first it
seems like this not that theoretical
right so back then doesn't know exactly
how this is going to go and kind of like
it's surprising yeah surprising
territory yeah and C7 C5
on the agenda potentially even crazily
enough e6e5 we'll keep an eye on this
VAR uh take us around other games that
caught your interest yeah there are a
few games I like to show you this one as
a Kings Indian between Duda and
chefchenko and it's always nice to see a
sharp opening so let's take a look at
the current position here so here white
decided to go for the DTX C5 here
oftentimes we also see the move D5 you
have two options here to close the
center or play for D takes E5 if the
bishop is only three it's we see this
happening a lot capturing and opening up
the D file at some point Knight D5 could
be played here so he just played the
move H3 which is a normal move just to
prevent the move Knight G4 here another
option was here to play the move 95
immediately try to put pressure on the
queen and if you capture on D5 white
almost always takes back with the c pawn
and try to put the Rook on C1 this would
have been a big Advantage for white so
that's why on the Move Knight D5 black
needs to retreat with the queen only it
and try to play the move C6 but now we
have some moves after H3 C6 is played
and white has an option to put a queen
on C2 and try to put a rook on D1 the
main idea here is to try to put a Pawn
on C5 and see if they're reroute the
Knight on D2 C4 and D6 that's a
long-term plan but if white can do that
he might be slightly better here thank
you for and going to Marquee matchup
game between mvl and Wesley so once
again the Petra of Defense you know if
you're going to play E4 you gotta have
something against the Petrov as well as
the Berlin in this particular line
let's go for an isolated Queen Pond
position with the move C2 C4 uh one of
the advantages of an early Bishop F5 is
that you're defending the Knight on e4
so that when you make this very natural
move c2c4 you're giving yourself the
option of actually being able to capture
it without worrying about the Knight
hanging takes takes castles Rook E1
Knight D6 there it is the famous
isolated Queen Pawn weakness or strength
we will see and a lifetime head to head
in Rapid and the
Wow Let's play a couple of games yeah
and really really close rather uh small
Edge I would say but 41 draws boy these
players sure know each other Bishop D5
on the board very theoretical uh
discussion going on here VAR uh what
does the theory tell us statistically
speaking uh not that many games in
database only four I find and there's
one win for white and three draws the
bishop D5 is very interesting movie I
think he's trying to force the move C6
and then only then Retreat the bishop to
B3 and that way black cannot develop his
Knight to active Square on C6 so we can
look at couple of more moves after that
to see how it will go C6 Bishop goes on
B3 looks like white is actually a little
bit better here and you try to develop
the Knight Knight D7 right and now
Knight goes on C3 the Knight on D6 is a
little bit awkward here if you have a
Pawn on D5 then it's great to have a
knight on the six but in this position
it's not so clear if the Knight on D6 is
placed well here so Bishop F6 is one
option and then white can even start
with the move Bishop F4 here very
natural move attacking the Knight on D6
Knight B6 and Knight goes only five and
white is a little bit better here
because you don't have the the control
follow the D5 square and you don't have
this move in ibd5 which is desired to
try to blockade a D4 pawn and shut down
this bishop there's also some serious
pressure here on F7 and I think white is
a little bit better in this position if
you can get all his pieces out like this
uh if I could advocate for a second for
Wesley's position I'm upon grubbers you
know C7 C6 I'm off I'm all game Bishop
B3 I don't see my Bishop is now having a
significant role on the B1 diagonal let
me Switch
and Go Bishop G4 pinning the Knight
planning as you were suggesting VAR uh
Bishop F6 and just putting pressure on
the pawn on D4 if I could get white to
advance the pawn to D5 then my knight on
D6 is a heroic block hater is this
um Theory uh C6 Bishop B3 Bishop G4 no
there's no games in the data I think
it's pretty concrete now after Bishop G4
white should play the move H3
immediately immediately questioning the
bishop right and now you would take or
go back to each yeah sure I'm a pawn
Grabber take on F3 Knight B5 give me the
pawn Knight B5
um well actually white can just simply
develop Bishop E3 and now if you take on
D4 after the exchange the E7 Bishop is
hanging at the end of that line agreed
so Bishop F6 Bishop F6
now just Knight C3 developing oh man
you're supposed to play D5 I had this
brilliant brilliant answer for you uh
give me the okay take the pawn yeah of
course it looks very nice look I gotta I
now I got the support I've been dying
for it it's amazing guys but this is
just simply losing I think you just
never never gonna get to develop your
knight on B8 here I'll take with the
queen just so I'm not sure
Rook 81 and hide my queen somewhere uh
yeah I'm saying that I'm beginning to
feel it uh okay Queen B4 just hide the
queen somewhere and now 94 very
important actually can also start with
the move rookie for his version go Queen
A5 and just hang out but I I'm afraid of
94. yeah I'm kind of chilled by threats
of Queen takes I'm afraid of that engine
evaluation I see behind fireplace and
that too I'm afraid of the valuation as
well don't look it don't look now but
okay my pond grubbing it's too much too
much I I think I just uh I I I swallowed
a horse there but guess what the move
Bishop D5 is actually stunned uh Wesley
we don't see him I mean in fact we never
see him getting surprised I think he's
out of the book but we'll figure it out
the position is quite simple
well maybe Messi doesn't take the pawn
right
and look at those beautiful Knights on
the b-file right okay so we have what
would we call this as well a classical
four nights and night on B3 castles
castles you know this is for me I think
where you know experience and natural
feeling
instincts come in uh as a sicilian
player which I am not
it's always difficult to judge when you
want to play A6 at certain positions so
you can play B5 and when you want to
play A5 and I have to tell you I've
never gotten that right balance of the
sense of when you're supposed to do this
you see a move like A5 and you go well
gee I mean I'm playing A4 and my
Knight's gonna hang out here and you're
not going to be able to kick me your
Knight's not going so white gets an
outpost on B5 but black doesn't get an
outpost right yeah so it's always one of
those things where I I feel like you
know am I did I do it wrong you're right
okay Bishop
Bishop F3 putting the kibosh on a d65
ideas for the moment Bishop E6
reinforcing that also Rook is tickling
E5 don't forget Knight B5 and here we go
I mean the fight for this C3 is coming
ideas in the similar positions that
black can play D5 and sacrifice the pawn
when Knight is on B4 there's this idea
to
use it so if y takes back on D5 right
Bishop F5
oh I'm not sure if it works here but
I've seen this idea before that is uh
that's interesting because you know it's
funny I wanted to play C3 Knight C2 Rook
takes E5 this is what I wanted to happen
until I stopped myself and realize that
you're actually going to go Bishop C2
might be better
suddenly if my queen goes takes and now
if I take Bishop takes B4 and isn't it
brilliant of us that we have to put when
we played A5 and black replaced the two
knights with the two Bishops on B3 and
B4 remarkable uh cool stuff uh VAR jump
in on this game between Lavon and
radislav
um what's going on actually D5 is
necessary it's the best move in this
position to try to open up the position
and you have to follow it up with that
move Bishop F5 suggested by Nazi and
we'll go a couple of more moves deeper
this year there's some very cool move
there white has so after D5 he takes D5
and if you capture with the bishop on D5
you're dropping the E5 pawn and white is
white is better there so you need to
play the move Bishop F5 here now
attacking on C2 but white has this
dangerous move D6 and it looks like
you're in big trouble because your
Bishop is now trapped so Bishop takes C2
only move
D takes E7 Queen takes E7 and here white
has a few different moves here but I
like this idea Queen D4
so 24. taking advantage of the fact if
you take on D4 we have Rook takes E7 and
here looks like it's still close to
equality Bishop takes B3 Rook takes E5
now we see the idea behind the move
Queen D4 that you take only five with
the tempo and now black plays the move
Queen D7 trying to exchange the queens
and the fact that you're not quite
developed yet if you had your bishopod
then white would have been actually much
much better in this position so here you
you can play Queen H4
and but looks like Knight C2 and black
is okay here it's it's like a crazy line
Rook B1 Bishop Bay two
uh the bishop H6 I can't follow
dang Bishop takes B1 Bishop G7 if you
take you actually get uh yeah because of
Queen G5 check and king h8 queen F6 and
then the Rook comes to G5 with the mate
here so that's why you cannot uh
take here so be sure so you have to find
the only move Queen D2 now yes so
obviously yeah any good Grandmaster
would immediately recognize you yeah of
course we're not gonna see this but it
ends inequality at the end
in their head to head a very dominating
score for Lavon four wins against two
draws how a few games they've played in
Rapid and the two
surprising things first of all uh such a
few games as you mentioned but also a
dominators score redislav actually is a
very very difficult man to beat let's
just uh wow but thank you for that far
those are some and we did not see D5 and
Lavon has gotten the opportunity to play
c2c3 and
my immediate reaction is a little bit
one of shock because this feels like it
could be terrible like really bad
it's not it's not that bad yes sir I
mean yeah he has to play Knight D3 which
is the best which is late 93. I thought
he had to play the ugly movement yeah
here white is a little bit better okay
um Knight D3 let's take a look so Queen
takes D3 plate Bishop takes B3 and the
move Bishop G5 uh Bishop is actually
well placed here on B3 is putting
pressure on A4 and black uh should
continue here with the move H6 or two
options H6 or queen B6 can be played
here if you play the move H6
Bishop takes F6 for example right Bishop
takes F6
Pawn Yeah if you take back with the
Knight then you are in trouble after the
move Rook C6 and now you're pinned clear
and if you play uh Queen B5
now there is this very important move
Rook B6 first attacking the queen and
only then picking up the Knight on D6 so
that's why you cannot take back with the
Knight on D6 so you have to play Queen
takes D6 here and then Queen takes D6
Knight takes a six Rook C7 white is up
upon here but black has two Bishops and
once again this bishop 1v3 is very
strong so white is a little bit better
here but I think black has a
compensation and chances to hold this
position thank you but I think we should
point out their time levon's been Blitz
and he has 24 minutes on the clock and
rather slaps down to 13 minutes
significant nearly two to one advantage
on the clock and by the way that time
management is so crucial rapid chess is
like that weird mixture you you can go
into a thing like you can In classical
chess but then you're playing Blitz and
uh these guys you just can't spot them
three five minutes on the clock it it
the the difference is too great uh
jumping again to the game of Wesley so
because he's gotten an isolated Queen
Pawn position where he went for the
Knight D7 to B6 routine where you kind
of look at the Knight and you go well
thank you what is the night doing on B
what's the business of the night yes
maybe he wanted to go to C4 but after 95
that doesn't seem plausible exactly well
uh 95 is nice you're actually utilizing
the pawn on D4 okay rookie eight we can
see what black has in mind he wants to
play Bishop E6 simply to neutralize his
Bishop Bishop F4 Bishop E6 we're still
in the theory books and what does the
theory tell us statistically speaking
VAR is white done well from this
specific position or it's only one game
played only one in 1980 between Anatoly
carpool and oscarpano really okay that's
the throwback uh throwback Tuesday yes
so I I think what Wesley did it's okay
and he's only very very slightly worse
in this position but at least he got his
development out and once he exchanges
the light score Bishop I think the most
of the pressure will be gone from F7
here let's take a look at a few next few
moves how the game can develop here sure
and after the Bish I like this more
Bishop B6 a lot now just to liquidate
the strong Bishop on B3 here white can
continue with a force for example one
idea to try to play A5 but that move
will be met by the move A5 simply to
prevent A5 and H6 ideas and
engines wants to play very slowly like
with H3 but again you can just also play
a useful H6 and sort of ask okay what is
the next uh what are you gonna do next
so in this position if you play
Bishop C2 is one option you see just to
keep the bishop at some point maybe play
the move Queen did you try to put some
pressure again we see the same idea
black wants to exchange the light Square
bishop and uh you know Bishop B3 Bishop
B6 white can do something something else
in this position but it's very hard to
see how white is going to proceed in
this position it's not a clear plan that
he has right now
thank you for that part let's go to our
other co-leader and that is the game of
Duda when we left it we left it these
parts h2h3 uh Kings Indian
um
position outlined by VAR just a moment
ago C7 C6 very useful taking away the D5
square and as far as mentioning the
entire concept from White's point of
view is he wants to Aspire to play the
move C5 maybe reroute the Knight Knight
D2 to C4 a2a3 prepping B4 and C5 well
immediately the Knight goes to C5 gift
meet the pawn queen C2 again prepping
b2b4 in here I think it's an actually
um kind of a key moment if you will
because I think a lot of King's Indian
defense players would be attracted I
want to say to the move A5 B4 and play
those positions and where do you want to
play Queen side or King side
you you can't play both so you have to
make a determination and I think this
move says it all it's sort of like oh it
says okay I'm going to play for a king
side attack based on Knight H5 F4 and
you can go ahead and do your queen side
expansion with B4 and the players are
now up to date that was always
interesting but yes let's take a stand
look at the standings first sure uh
Wesley and Duda sharing clear first it's
the dude that Wesley John Duda Wesley so
show as they have been dominating I live
on and clear third and like seeming
clear fourth
now uh taking us again to the game of
due to a co-leader move F7 F5 uh VAR if
you can break down the theoretical stats
for our viewers and let them know who
has done what in these positions uh not
so much theory in the current position
only three games played and black scored
a win and a loss and a draw in this
position it's a it's a very dynamic
position yesterday they want to say
three results
three results I've played this type of
positions uh have a little bit of
experience and once the move F5 comes in
you have to start looking for that move
F4 next so I was trying to see if I can
play the move C5 which I mentioned
earlier just try to get the control of
the D6 but it's not so easy so I will
show how the game can develop if you
play the move C5 which is the main idea
for white here so C5 comes in now you
want to play the move Rook D6 as well
sometimes in this position then Bishop
C4 and put some pressure and also get
the control of the D file but here black
needs to play the immediate move F4 now
removing the Bishop from E3 you don't
really want to put it I don't want to
put it on D2 here because then it's very
passive here but it's a possibility here
I was trying to bring the bishop back to
B2 here try to have a pressure here only
five but then black has a very active
move Knight D4 okay and now you have to
move the queen and you don't really want
to take on D4 because after he takes
defordance big problems here on this
diagonal Knight has to go and there's a
D3 possibility and The Rook is hanging
on A1 so and if you have to move the
queen let's say you play the move Queen
B2 or queen D3 black will develop the
bishop only six next and Rook 88 is
coming up and black is actually slightly
better in this position by the way Duda
did not push C5 he played Knight A4 I
think his idea is to play Knight C5 5
and maybe try to exchange that good
night on E6 absolutely that's an idea
try to exchange and also lend the bishop
on C5 black has a few options here one
idea that comes to mind is this night
bring the Knight into the game here
night uh to F4 and putting pressure on
E2 as well so oftentimes when you see
this move is happening white almost
automatically plays the move Bishop F1
in this position but here it's not so
clear because there are some other
options for black take on e4 Queen takes
E4 and now Knight G5 comes in exchanging
this Knight on F3 and uh now
yeah watch out for Bishop F5 Knight H3
is also threat and Bishop F5 black is
actually doing really really well here
so there is some danger here for Duda
okay Knight A4 uh picking up on our game
between
um Daniel dayak and Mac Magnus for a
moment
um the situation has certainly calmed
down since the uh Pawn sacrifice he's
got the pawn back he won however
position is very simplified and does
Magnus have any winning chances here
well you know we we've spoken about that
in the
um other games these endings I've always
liked the rook and Bishop combination
against the rook and Knight combination
when uh pawns are on both flanks uh this
is classical if you had put the pawn on
B6 I'd say black is significantly better
the double pawns really reduces the
opportunity to win the game I I think
that the chances of a draw are sad to
say for Maggie's fans extremely high I
mean whites white white is looking to
play Rook to D1 bring this Knight if
we're to remove the Rooks off the board
Knight versus Bishop with the double
pawns then white would be playing for a
win correct
the chances of white being better are
good winning is is strong but if the
pawns were undoubled then I would say
okay then Black's Bishop might might
have something to say but we're really
splitting hairs here on this one I think
the chances of a draw really high uh you
mentioned Anish Gary my pick for the
tournament go on each
um it could play the role of a spoiler
he's up against Richie report who is
cursing himself for leaving so many
points on the table somehow they got
into a pretty balanced position
and yeah what can I say really Pleasant
Advantage for white
because of because of D6 because of D6
because of black snide on A6 the pawn
structure slightly like C6 is slightly
weaker right so if I go like Knight C5 I
mean it's one of those things if you can
exploit it right now
now see I'm with you I like White's
position but can I exploit maybe bishop
E3 Bishop E3 okay
oh yes I'm not going to allow you that
uh I guess uh I just bring the Knight
back into civilization I agree you've
got a decent six or D7 yeah okay I yeah
you got uh
a Freer hand let's say for for the time
being keep our eye on that uh back over
to you VAR jump in What caught your uh
attention uh in this round seven
let's take a look at the level on skin
we have some more development in that
game the couple of more moves played and
I like White's position I think it's
going to be a difficult defense for
vitashek in this game so we left it off
around the move uh Bishop G5 in this
position and whatasha didn't play the
more active H6 to try to give up the
pawn to get a compensation so he played
The Rook C6 a little bit more defensive
and now we see that clearly he's on
defense here trying to make sure he he
hangs on to the pawn on D6 here so Rook
easy one played uh I'm not sure about
this move it's it's a possibility but
another idea level one head here is try
to remove the strong Bishop I really
like this move Bishop D1 here because if
you somehow exchange it black shouldn't
exchange but then white is going to have
a really a huge Advantage here almost
winning position here so this bishop D1
would have been very strong and if you
play the move Bishop C4 then you can
play the move Queen G3 and now the
strong Bishop is gone from B3 then white
can play the move Bishop C2 Rook 81 with
a slightly better position but in the
game Levon played uh Rook ec1 he wants
to play the move C4 here and just simply
to trap the bishop
and now Bishop C4 played to prevent that
and queen D1 Knight D7 and Bishop Bishop
E3
I'm just trying to control the diagonal
and Knight C5 Bishop takes C5 and
now Rook takes C5 is one option
and if you can exchange the live score
Bishop then you're going to be clearly
better and that's what he's trying to do
with the move Bishop E2 I think he will
not exchange so he played the move
Bishop E6 here and you can get a
slightly better position after the move
C4 because just now you fix the pawn on
D6 and black can never play the move D5
but then you're no longer going to have
the option to play the move before here
so I don't think Levon will play this
move but on the other hand you need to
watch out for the possibility of D5
trying to get rid of this backward Pawn
for black so I think Levon misplayed it
slightly and black is doing okay now
yeah thank you for that uh VAR and I I'm
looking at the game between Duda and
Carol and ever since I saw this move
Knight A4 I'm really warming up the
black's position actually because I'm
not a big fan of
what white has done and I'm seeing the
moves F4 and Knight G5 as prescribed a
moment ago by VAR so
um let's just see F4 right we're going
to drop back
I don't know I'm gonna guess to see one
I'm having a little trouble here maybe
D2 so I can go to C3 okay fair and yeah
if you can get Knight to D3 and Bishop
to C3 all in on time but I'm gonna go
King hunting specifically I'm looking at
an opportunity to playing Bishop takes
H3 and or Knight takes H3 kind of
encouraging yeah King's Indian defense
positions always make me uncomfortable
with life yes I'm attacking on the queen
side but I'm attacking ponds while black
is attacking my king exactly by the way
he did not play F5 F4 instead King
hunting he's still going for at night on
E6 to F4 and what R said is it's almost
a ritual that whenever you see this
Knight dropping in hitting the bishop
hitting the pawn you almost always want
to play Bishop F1 but you do have to be
a little bit careful that uh you know uh
you're getting busy that C6 Pawn is
hanging otherwise F takes e right Queen
E4 Bishop F5 would be a win for black
exactly Bishop F5 if you put your Pawn
back on B7 you're super happy right
um okay but is there well
you you have to meet the needs of the
position I mean uh White's King is under
attack you need more you you you know
assaults there you go Bishop F1
dangerous are we gonna see G5 is that
asking too much or is G5 is storming the
ramparts G5 is a possibility this ninth
ef4 was the best way to play for black
so if jenko is definitely playing the
Right Moves in that position guys when
you were looking at the move F4 uh for
some reason with the inclusion of this
B5 move it's no longer that good then
that Bishop B2 Bishop C3 white is doing
really really well actually in this
position and another main issue in this
position for black is this A4 move is
coming and it's extremely strong for
white and will open up the a file so he
made the right decision by not closing
the position here because right here the
evaluation was like plus two for white
okay so Knight e62 yeah yeah so yeah
this is this is the correct way to play
and now
yeah he can take uh on e4 really in
Queen takes E4
and now black has this interesting move
Queen B7
que pasa defending the pawn and now
getting ready to play the move Bishop F5
Rook to David six
and Knight D5
kind of chopping trapping there who's
trapping whom trapping the rook and now
we now we understand Queen B7 because
Bishop takes B5 you take with the queen
okay yes uh weird stuff going on but I'm
sure Queen B7 is an E5 Pawn hanging yeah
you can take only five but then uh the
position really opens up and this is
actually gonna favor Black because
you're opening up the dark Square bishop
and then after move Knight D5 Bishop F5
will come in it's just somehow White's
pieces are not coordinated that well
here so a little bit of an advent not a
big adventure but an event Advantage for
black here after this move 95 so you
have to play Bishop D4 here wow Bishop
F5 Queen H4
Rook ae8 Knight bd3 and the queen queen
is also a little bit misplaced here on
H4 so to me
to me why it looks fine but yeah and he
has to argue with the engine yeah he has
gone uh for the line that you're
prescribing with F5 takes E4 of our
Queen takes E4 Queen B7 not an intuitive
move but I defend C6 that's such an
unnatural move did you you so you do
want to play Bishop F5 so very badly
right that and and you don't want to
lose c-secs true and it's because of
Bishop B5 tactics yeah you would
consider a queen B7 otherwise right the
other the other desirable thing is you'd
like to keep your queen let's say
hounding uh on the king side but Rook D6
would really
Queen takes it now this is the Moment of
Truth for Carol if he finds it is also
Knight D5 here okay that's what he
played 95. that's far more
I want to say natural right I would
definitely take on D5 though Rook D5
okay uh we'll take back Queen takes and
Bishop E6 because I don't want to lose
the rook and connect my Rooks of course
you can play Queen E4 or queen C6
Queen C6
I'm likely just to play A6 and queen E4
are you are you inviting me to make a a
repetition or a pet on the queen say
queen D5 okay just wanted to make sure
that when you sacrifice the exchange it
wasn't
ah equalize in fact what is the
evaluation
um VAR because it's a totally
double-edged position very very slightly
better for a block here and I think yeah
yeah that we might see a repetition if
we get to that position but uh black can
play for a win Rook D5 is necessary here
because Bishop S5 is extremely strong
and then you know Knight is also going
to thread and take only three and then
that E4 move will be really really
strong opening up the dark Square Bishop
so Duda really needs to go uh through
the small Rook D5 and let's take a look
at couple of more moves after that Rook
takes D5 C takes D5 Queen D5 check
Bishop E6 is forced as you mentioned the
Rook on 8 is hanging and here uh you can
play you have two moves here you can
play the move Queen E4 or you can play
the move Queen C6 so Queen C6 I think is
another option we could see because now
you're attacking the pawn on B5 and for
a moment you're not too worried about
the move E4 because you have Knight D4
in this position so black actually can
just play a very calm move here A6 just
simply to protect the spawn it's very
important this B5 Pawn in this position
because if this Pawn Falls then we're
going to see the Knight jumping on C4
and D6 to that desired Square to go to
so it's very important to keep that pawn
there and here actually white just
continues like its normal uh just Place
A4 trying to liquidate the B5 Pawn here
and very complicated position and Rook
fc8 is an option you can even play the
move Knight F6 here with ideas Bishop D5
it's it's close to equality but a lot of
imbalance in this position
wonderful end of times for The Players
uh now see that's going to be a a key
factor going forward right there both
well dude us down to nine minutes and
Carol has 10 minutes
it's about equal slightly less for Duda
I have the feeling that dude is time
management has been a little bit off I
think in the games with Wesley and
others he really got into that 30 10
second increment period there
um let's go to another of our co-leader
this game and that's Wesley so when we
left it we had seen this kind of dance
with the Bishops uh Wesley was trying to
trade light Square Bishops and what VAR
was suggesting is they could have made
some kind of repetition with Bishop F5
to E6 none of that happened instead what
did happen was D5
in a sense
that's great you you win a Tempo and
everything's good but you you block your
own Bishop right you've blocked your own
Bishop after Bishop F5 Queen F3 a light
White's game it's it's rather free
er uh your your pieces control more
space but at the same time white is
getting ready to play on the king side
right yeah but at the same time there's
no real weaknesses in Black's Camp the
night on D6 is actually pretty darn
useful and the last move G7 G6 just
fortifies everything
um but okay if this queen were active
let's say I have Pawn on A5 on A4 the
queen was doing something I'd like black
for the moment I think it's
balanced white is slightly better yes
okay cool and the clocks Wesley has been
great with his time management by the
way not in this game because I think he
was not expecting this opening the
bishop D5 most surprised him so he's
down to five minutes while NBL has more
than 11 minutes
and let's just go to the Magnus game and
just check the clocks on that one well
we know that Danielle likes to get into
time trouble yeah we might even say he's
a little bit addicted so he has 30
seconds against 17 minutes
position is quite equal and he can
manage to still draw this but it's still
unpleasant and against Magnus yeah
that's so dangerous that I mean that's
almost a prescription for Disaster by
the way Magnus has made some pretty nice
progress we got rid of the double Pawn
that was the progress I was uh about to
mention and captures captures Rook to D2
here's here's what I'm saying about the
bishop versus uh the Knight Dynamic is
that the bishop on E6 you know it's
actually swaying in two directions and
putting considerable pressure on both
flanks the Knight needs to be somewhere
and usually if it doesn't have an
outpost that's being outplayed sorry
Rook A1 you were I was a little bit
surprised by Rook A1 because that looks
so passive couldn't have white played
rookie too because there's black
exchanges and green the other Rook to D2
I can just simply play Knight C3 and
yeah I'm slightly worse but it's only
temporary I'm bringing my king to iwan I
think you're making a good point so if I
give you a check
um maybe I can just drop back rookie one
right or I don't know I can't take and
play King age too okay that was my
question did you want to put your king
um let's say I don't know out of Dodge
here I didn't want to but I didn't have
a choice okay so something like A4 takes
C5 I can see
you know
and by the way we asked yesterday the
viewers what you thought Magnus was
going to do was he going to win three
win two win one and the question today
slightly different question today the
question was Magnus plays all three
Romanian players uh Will he win a game
win the game okay 84 percent go said yes
I'm gonna go with the friends I'm gonna
say he's gonna win a game today he's
gonna get out that has to be a gift well
he has to win I mean but don't become
number one he doesn't have two black
pieces yes so it wouldn't be easy for
sure but in this game again uh the the
the the time disadvantage speaks
speaks uh volumes here uh quickly going
to the game between Anish and Richie all
the pieces have come off
Bishops of the same color ending
looks like a draw yeah just I'm I'm
looking how do I invade as long as
Black's King can just keep white king
out
should be a draw although you know you
play a move like
I was about to say you play a move like
G5 G4 keeping the pawns on dark squares
No it should be a draw yeah
um what do you have for asvar things
have changed in dude Queens have come
off the board oh okay
did we see yes we did see the exchange
sacrifice and after Bishop Queen D6 is
an indication to me that Duda thinks the
exchange sacrifice is good for him is he
right VAR I think after Queen D6 is
worse yeah so he had to keep that
structure that you know healthy
protective protective on C5 and let's
let's see the current position now after
Queen D6 so Queen D6 is played
exchanging the queens and now this this
exponent is not as strong as it would
have been on C5 so E4 is played trying
to open up the diagonal for the bishop
so Knight D4
is play the only move otherwise you're
losing the piece on B2 right so Bishop
D7
and this is the current position here
here I get very very nervous for white
because the Knight on B2 is actually
dominated at the moment it can't jump to
C4 or D3 yeah he has uh he had uh two
options here A4 is one of the best moves
another option was to play the move
Knight to D1 with the idea to go to C3
that was another alternative but against
91 black will play the strong move Rook
C8 to prevent that and this position is
actually better for black so he played a
logical move A4 he really wants to see a
move P takes A4 so Knight A4 Knights C5
will come into play this Knight is still
out of place on H5 here so there is
definitely some compensation here A6 is
the best move here for black to try to
control the B5 a takes B5
C takes B5 and here you don't want to
exchange the Rooks then you you you
don't have any more Rooks left and black
will be better there so you have to play
look B1 here that's such an ugly move
not an easy move to play but you have a
clear plan you want to capture the pawn
on B5 now because you just protected
your knight and here black has
Knight G3
uh what
and if you take this is absolutely crazy
Rook A3 now attacking the bishop on E3
and the bishop moves you're gonna drop
the Knight on D4 and this is very very
strong because if you play the move
Knight D1 it's going to run into Rook
takes E3 so
very very strange tactic the move Knight
G3 bringing the Knight into the game and
actually attacking the bishop on a fun
this is a very strong idea but uh
unclear if chefchenko will find this I
don't even think dude I will play Rook
B1 well for me uh A4 A6 I always ask
myself you know what are my trumps what
are my opponents trumps and the idea of
opening up the a file would be an
anathema to me because I'm thinking
black is the one with the Rooks why
should I be opening up the files
especially for the Rook on A8 so after
the move A4 uh Carol is thinking about
Asics just played
hype I would find the question is what
else can white do yeah exactly it's it's
this night is so bad on B2 that scares
me yeah and he needs a lot of moves to
get in if you're somehow magically on B3
then you go Knight C5 you're super happy
um but it's it's really difficult to
bring this piece into the play here
um and if you try to close the position
let's say with A5 this is actually a
very bad now Bishop E5 just simply
picking up the pawn on this exactly like
it's just winning
a little bit worried about do this
position because Bishop E5 sure is
attractive uh to me Wesley so
um
mvl game we left it we left it after
H3 Knight D7 I think uh now see you were
saying to me what's the knife doing on
B6 well nothing let's get him back into
into uh the game 97 by Wesley trades
exchange that hero Knight on D6
yes hero Knight but two Bishops
G4
uh a lot of uh chess beating I don't see
it at the moment
King G7 and okay we'll keep an eye on
this because I just been told Magnus he
got the dream position from Wow rook and
Bishop versus Rook at night he's he's
done it again he is the master of
squeezing any position let me tell you
wow in his Heyday Anatoly karpov was
remarkable at doing precisely what we're
witnessing right here by uh
by Magnus and Knight E4
um
obviously he you don't like the Rook uh
in front of the pond I'm thinking of
Rook C4 but
on the other hand if you could get the
pawn to A2 the game is just over
and Rook C4 should just be winning yeah
yeah and uh Daniel's walking around but
he has 22 seconds on the clock yeah but
he's kind of I think I think it's not
just stress but I think he's the
realization is that he's just given
Maggie just a perfect opportunity and
they're you know he had a terrible day
one just terrible he righted the ship in
day two but uh this is a a horrible
start
for day three of the Rapids Rook C4
inviting The Rook trade the a pawn is
the worst Pawn for the night as well as
the H Pawn Rook A1 A4 there you go
and now just bring the camera king of f8
king of Faith Center and yeah
I'm suspecting that Knight C3 is going
to force us to play Bishop D7 but we
have it and I love your suggestion just
uh bringing the uh King like a like a
bees to honey you know escort the pawn
Maggie uh doing great uh what's
happening in uh the game with Duda for
just a moment our co-leaders uh he did
play Rook B1 wow the Moment of Truth
guys Knight G3 would they find this move
players are just playing like engines
all the time
yeah but I I tell you Knight G3 is not
on my radar because I'm looking at Rook
A3 I'm rooking it I don't know Rook to
C8 I'm looking at Rook A2 you know if
your threat is to take on on uh on B5
Rook A2 but then I'm thinking okay the
Knight is going to swing to C3 so I mean
you find night night G3 as you go
through your progression of moves right
but it's not obvious not at all and they
both uh are under five minutes okay so I
don't think 93 is something you play in
this time control right uh jumping
um for
what are the possibilities of Knight G3
come on be honest second best move I
don't think you're gonna like yesterday
but it's Bishop takes D4
giving up that Bishop just in order to
bring the Knight into the game Rook V8
which is a human move yes
For the Love of humanity uh Bishop yeah
the bishop takes D4 as giving up any
hopes of playing Bishop E5 captures D6 I
would find Bishop takes D4 very very
difficult that's the best people this is
this is not a bad move also guys rookie
beat it's
okay let's just jump back to Maggie
because we oh sorry uh Anish Gary and
Richie report uh draw as uh well a moral
victory for Anish as he finishes the
final position with an extra bishop and
I'm sorry to interrupt but we have to
jump to mvl's game because I think he's
up in exchange
and has a great position wow what just
happened well when we left it we left it
after the move 94 King G7 mvl broke
through with the move D6 he's eyeballing
Bishop F7 Knight D6 ideas Knight F6
ideas takes
oh so if Bishop takes G5 there is Queen
F7 and F4
is Queen takes F7 and Bishop takes G5
was the best move he had to play Bishop
takes G5 he did not he took with the
rook and mvl said thank you very much I
will
this King on oh my goodness this King on
H6 looks so vulnerable is going down in
this game no question about it and in
their head to head while it was close
Wesley had a small Edge I wanted to say
yeah three games or so after 40 draws or
41 draws like oh my gosh yeah I have
three more wins but this is that this is
kaputsky uh rooked to D3 to H3 or King
G2
and it's the vulnerable King on H6
what's the eval I imagine it's through
the roof yeah it's it's completely
losing here the best move here is just
Queen G8 actually just to exchange coins
because you know qg2 is actually a very
strong threat here kg2 and Rook H1
coming up as well that's amazing so you
really need to somehow trade Queens but
uh and end game is Just hopeless can we
take a look at what would happen if he
took with Bishop G5 Queen F7 King H6 F4
yeah let's go back to the move 26 this
moment Bishop takes G5 right
Queen F7 yep and you have to play the
move King H6 right okay
Rook takes E4
ah if you take on G5 I have Queen G5
Rook takes C4 and now you play the move
Bishop F6 uh-huh so this is just a
better version yeah well the king's not
as vulnerable yeah king is not one we
got Bishop C6 coming up at some point
some Queen B6 check is a threat Queen B6
check Queen takes B2 as well so this is
just uh you know it's a very massive
position but it's just equal at the End
by the way Queen G8 on the board so that
there was no uh Rook takes E6 check and
may Rook so pardon me just here I'm
threatening made it made
um with Rook takes G6 so Queen G8 came
uh well okay I mean that that that's
completely winning
surprise to exchange coins I thought
Queen F3 and go for checkmate I we came
commentators curse we came on the air I
said it's the Wesley so yonduda game
Wesley is going down and perhaps KIRO is
going to upset the other co-leader as uh
he is an exchange up and after Rook B8
Knight D1 Rook C8 Rook C3
and we've got Bishop D4 and Rook C1 come
in up thank you now I will take on day
four but that's a whole different kettle
of fish because this is a very nasty
looking pin and if you play Knights of
three the movies again G3 wait oh and
Rook f8 no what 93. I assume it's okay
Bishop F2 and E3 or something like that
yes
okay that one I can I can stand behind I
mean I can uh easily foresee Knight G3
and Rook f8 uh the previous attempt
okay let me catch up with the players
because they are glitzing what is the
um clock times clock time they both have
two and a half minutes
uh Bishop D4 and Rook C1 very very
suggestive Knight C3 Bishop takes
me I I understand that completely you
want to get rid that pawn on D6 if it
survives the longer it survives I want
to say the more you kind of get
concerned that it could play a factor
and now Knight takes E4 yep I would
expect Knight takes E4 to be played
hitting the bishop be amazing if Judah
survives this game too like actually
he's he's not his position is not that
bad now Bishop B7 and he just comes back
Knight C3
7 Knight C3 and you have to take on B4
now otherwise you're just dropping the
B5 on Rook takes before Rook takes C3
Knight B5 and uh
well it's an exchange but three versus
two on the king side White's chances of
draw yeah it's quite reasonable very
reasonable yeah wow uh
uh
cool stuff going on in this in this
round our opening round for day three in
the rapid is just and I hear this one is
also winning Lavon is winning okay that
he's saying hey guys is there any room
on the top for me
he's in clear third if he wins and
Wesley and Duda Don win which looks like
they won't hello hello I mean nice uh as
long as Magnus and Magnus has won his
first game our congratulations to the
world number one player uh welcome back
uh has
by the way that answers our polls
question he has one I went with the 84
percent there I had to go with the
majority by the way the final position
Nasi you're going to love because you
said bring the king to the queen side
and escort your Pawn home your words
and white resign not the best game that
Daniel will like to remember uh looks
like nvl just won NBL won his game and
this is the first loss for Wesley since
and Bucharest he was undefeated and
he's been playing he was 50 50 coming
into today three wins three draws
um
wow uh congratulations ah
nice uh no it was a great game by inviel
okay let's go to The Duda game versus
Cairo
we have to check LeBron because and
Lavon as well he's also trying to
convert his Advantage well the Lavon
game
um Lavon has this beautiful structure
there is some pressure however on F2
that whether temporary or not
um if I go Rook takes F7 let's just take
a look at the most direct Rook takes F7
Rook takes F7 Knight takes E5 Rook takes
F2 King H3 I'm threatening to take on F2
and take on E6 this resulting position
is better for white but I thought this
looks more dravish to me okay I think
that's why what would you like to prefer
to keep the pieces on the board okay uh
he exchanged the Rooks on F7 okay so far
so maybe Queen E4 Queen E4 looks good
Queen E4 looks good
that makes a lot of sense you're just
because white has a long-term Advantage
here they're both right
um how am I supposed to defend this Pawn
uh am I supposed to defend the pawn
Queen C
Queen E4 on the board
um and now maybe just H4 and improve my
position you can also play Rook F5
Rook F5 okay Rook F5 something similar
keeping
coordination
but long term these double Palms on the
e-file uh feels like yeah Rook F5 your
suggestion on the board of our it feels
like
this should really be to result game
yeah this is a big Advantage C5 is a
very good move I think here just to give
up the C pump but pick up on B7
okay as one option another option is
just to play the move Rook D2 here Rook
D2 I for some reason I find myself
attracted to H3 and G4 yeah that's
coming up also maybe H4 and try to put
up on H5 you've played Rook D2 Rook
David too
he has the time Advantage as well Levon
has four and a half minutes and radoslav
has 39 seconds
also uh Lavon throughout his whole
career I've always admired his handling
of the clock uh he always seems to be
the one putting a little bit more
pressure on the on his opponent's clock
I think it's something a good habit that
he
inculcated within himself throughout his
career Queen C7 on the board
um and again I just want to go to the
co-leader Jan and
um Carol for just a moment because they
do have that three versus two ending
my first impression is it is it's easier
to draw than to win
um black is for choice but uh I think
it's definitely a draw but in time
trouble it's very easy to make a mistake
so black does have a chance to
win this but okay we'll see I mean do
that undefeated in this tournament so
and Kira looking for us first week yes
okay yes we'll keep that in mind we'll
jump back then to the Lavon aronian game
as Lavon played after Queen C7 night
didn't see that coming night why did he
want the Knight on H4
um
that looks like a miscue to me uh heel
just repeats to gain time right after
the back probably right G6
it can be annoying on G6 I see and we do
have I'm seeing
duda's game and the last move let's
switch back to Duda to match at least
our camera there as we're seeing Knight
D1 is the danger that's the alert
because the desirable Bishop E3 is three
and then King F3 we do have uh king so
I'm saying Knight D1 oops you would play
Bishop E3
well
and take with the King
yeah okay Carol actually played uh King
F7 uh bringing the king maybe to D5 and
94 would be more or less a dream I'm not
sure how you're going to cross the E6
Square for the time maybe a white shirt
Play Bishop G5 now so King cannot come
closer Bishop G5 makes sense yeah
and let's jump back to Levon as this
technical ending isn't as fun
whoa whoa whoa whoa where did that on
one in exchange he did play Knight to G6
and radislav said you know what let me
take it uh
I get a pawn I get a good Bishop
and I'm happy
uh I've got Queen F1 check but black
king is not happy do I have Rook C2 here
let's go going for a Checkmate let's see
Rook C2 so you've got the back but okay
King age four okay H4 no no mas huh no
more checks
missed a very strong move guys after the
move F4 yes it was a move he had Bishop
E3 here if we go back before taking on
G6 yeah
right here Bishop E3 was actually
equalizing
very strong move easy to miss and in the
current position though it's Checkmate
right just completely lost it's made
enough one check on the board King it
made in five
and he's he's staring down the game and
Lavon saying hey would you guys take
care of the co-leaders for me and uh
very nice game and with this one he
actually surpasses Wesley now yes and if
Duda loses he's going to be actually
clear first wow by the way Lavon is
having a kind of a second win I was with
him in a Dusseldorf earlier in the year
in February where Lavon won clear first
in a very very strong tournament and he
was very uh
pleased with himself let's say uh he
looked quite happy in that one too yeah
and uh Duda uh trying to hold on to a
draw and trying to keep his first place
hopes alive how is he doing VAR
I think he's doing okay he's holding one
thing uh shevchenko needs to avoid is
just exchange the knights if the knights
come off the board black white will just
put the bishop only three and it's just
going to be a very very easy draw here
right he needs to keep the knights on
the board but it's very hard to make
progress
um I think he's trying to bring his King
into the game but again
um even if you bring the king
to C4 then what do you do because you
don't have candy 3 I have Knight C1
check that's and at some point you have
to you know watch out for your pawns as
well maybe white can start attacking the
H7 Pawn so it's very hard to get closer
now with the king so I think Duda is
holding this well pretty comfortably
well just like so King C4
um
oh right now black is threatening maybe
Knight F2 and King D3 yes Knight F2
probably right two versus two yeah I
well I'll go for it yeah yeah okay so
with the move King C4 Knight F2 and that
move by the way Bishop E3 does invite
the disruptive Rook A3 and Knight takes
what do you think of the Knight versus
Rook three versus two but the pawn
structure is is damaged yes uh the issue
there is the white will put the Knight
on F4 we do that's gonna make it
difficult for your king to get closer so
even if you take only three F takes E3
you can you can't really bring the king
uh close and then let me be the Devil's
Advocate and say well yes I can I can
put the King on D2 your knight will be
on G2 just holding me off he's stating
and King on F2 and going back and forth
but I'll get Rook have check right
um
it's getting closer and closer dudas uh
on on the Cliff's Edge here
night uh so the question is should he
take and he's done it disrupted the king
oh maybe he didn't go he didn't go to D2
he went back and he's looking to maybe
swing his King around to the E five
square and dude I immediately played H5
because less pawns on the board easier
to draw that is always the um actually
against him of King City also yesterday
the H5 was a very strong idea against
King C3 as well I didn't realize that
the motif actually against King C3 as
well H5 and just exchanging the pawns by
the way again a very very important
Motif when you're in these positions
with the minor piece versus the Rooks
every Pawn trade brings the draw closer
and I love that move H5 it was perfectly
timed and immediately when the pawns
came off the board the table base uh
left up in front of me and said you know
shouting to the world that due to saving
the game now
Rook A7
just I mean
those tricky tricky nights you know you
walk into Forks King F4 so I think you
realm is the big winning chance one he
didn't take on D4 and won Rook C1 yeah
one moment
yeah with Knight G3 that would have been
that would have been very special and uh
dinner was on Lavon uh King D6
um I like the idea of planting my night
on F6 we we know that Knights love
outposts so moves like I would find
attractive would be G4 G5 I think others
might find you know you you King King
coming to to try to eat that pawn but I
would find the move G4 was attracting G4
on the board play G5 sync your knight on
F6 and a draw should be in the offing
also now you can play King G5 King H6
and then G5 and Knight F6
by the way commentators curse as uh we
came on I was saying we had a 60
decisive scores in day one versus 20 in
day two guess what this round is holding
so far three wins 60 60 right and maybe
eighty percent no I like unlikely 60 uh
G4 and E4
both
and Rook to eat one
you can get five and now we've looked at
one just now here F4
funnily enough I I really was uh so
fixated on putting my knight on F6 I I
wanted to play G5 and a knight to F6
King F5 for me is a little bit of a
surprise I I'm guessing he wanted to
meet Rook check actually with maybe King
G5 maybe thinking that question if of
course this is not going to happen but
if pawns were to get exchanged look
versus night of course is a draw but
with few seconds on the clock do you
think I'm gonna try it yeah no I would
play it and then you would play it for
50 moves no no I would pay probably for
2025 moves I remember
um
I had Rook at night I had the king in
Rook it was a
U.S championship game and my opponent
moved his Knight away from his King gave
me a chance to win and I didn't seize
the moment I missed the moment to win
whenever you have a rook at night versus
uh you pardon me whenever you have a can
night versus the king and Rook it's
incumbent upon the night to stay close
to the king don't go
uh away bar Jump Right In yeah what's
going on I'm watching this guys it seems
like white is making a lot of products
like this making progress it's uh it's a
little bit worrisome for chefchenko
isn't there's no way he's gonna win this
game but he needs to be careful I don't
like to at all like the way he played
it's just a very passive Rook on G7 here
it's still of course a draw but uh there
there are some ways actually to mess up
this position now and uh still should be
still should be a draw here but the
white is doing really well here Knight
H5 uh yeah I think he can force the
repetition now after Rook G8 Knight F6
uh but the pawn only six is is very
threatening I'll be a little bit worried
here
okay now and I think we're gonna see a
rep repetition because I hear you of our
I mean that part that Fawn is uh because
I remember where we started the guy was
on F2 and then you know after the
capture got to E3 E4 E5 E6 so it's uh
definitely there were some progress now
okay okay now we'll see yeah the
liquidation and draw okay very very hard
pod draw and as we finish up this round
seven let's just check in on our friends
at Q Boutique as uh we have to ask want
to take your game on the go well guess
what pick out a World Chess Hall of Fame
roll up chessboard in your favorite
color and hit the road these boards are
flexible easily clean and always lay
flat 20 inch square board with two 0.25
inch squares screen printed ink on vinyl
they are available in all kinds of
colors green red purple pink and blue
don't forget the chest pieces and travel
bag for all your chest needs go to
cubeboutique St louis.com and let's jump
over uh to Christian in Warsaw as chest
fever hits the capital city
thanks guys uh what an amazing round of
Chess and I'm going to cover a couple of
games that you guys uh didn't look as
much at and we're going to start with
this clash between uh Anish giri and
Richie Rapport and we know Anish has
been struggling in this event shared
last with chefchenko is not the place
that we are used to see Anish uh in and
let's take a look at what happened in
this game he started off with E4 and
Richie report invites a fight
immediately an imbalance in the position
giving the advantage to White because we
know the philidor is going to offer
white a slight Advantage out of the
opening Richie is not signaling that
he's trying to equalize out of the
opening he's just trying to create an
imbalanced game and let's take a look at
what happened Bishop to E7 Bishop to F4
D5 Knight to B5 is a very decent move
for white but this invites the type of
complications that definitely Richie was
looking to get in the position Castle C6
take on D5 take on D5 and this was a
critical moment King to B1 which was
played by Anish is obviously the natural
move in the position but you have other
options as well one of them very not
natural I have to say is C4 that weakens
the king a little bit but what you're
trying to get to achieve as white is
you're trying to stop black from
finishing their development and for
example the Queen by the way take a look
at this queen it doesn't have that many
squares Queen to d8 potentially and now
Bishop to D3 and this is a critical move
in the position because the Knight on D4
is double you cannot touch it Knight
takes D4 Bishop takes H7 goodbye this is
game over I'm going to uh discovery
check against your queen and that's all
she wrote so you cannot do that King to
B1 was played C4 was a better
alternative but let's keep it going
Knight to B3 and after Bishop to E6 this
invites uh the end game with Queen to D5
which we've seen in that game after that
there were no imbalances in the position
I have to say Richie probably handled
the defense passive tasks of that end
game quite well we're not going to go
too far in that one but a critical move
in this position was Queen to C1 to
attack the queen on D5
and it looks like the queen doesn't
actually have that many squares if you
go to F5 well thank you very much that's
another Tempo on the Queen Bishop to D3
you don't have places to hide so
probably the best movie in the position
would be to go Queen to H5 the problem
is that I can continue harassing that
Queen F3 I'm going to go G4 next move
for example Knight to D7 you're still a
little bit behind in development as
black G4 and where do you put the queen
queen to A5 to go back to C7 or to B6
unfortunately you cannot touch that
square because Queen to A5 my knight on
B3 will just capture that Queen you have
to stay on H4 this is not looking good
not looking comfortable for the black
queen and this would have given Anish
quite a significant Advantage I have to
say he did not do that he took on a D5
and the game fizzled out into a draw
quite quickly afterwards now let's take
a look at the game between Bogdan Daniel
The Arc and Magnus
you guys see uh saw what happened in the
opening phase an early Pawn Sacrifice by
Magnus with this move a bishop to B4 I
really like this but bognan seemed to
have been ready for it because he
blitzed out his moves more or less and
keep an eye on the clock by the way I
would I will keep you updated on that
take on D5 Bishop takes D5 Castle Knight
to E2 Rook to d8 Castle Bishop takes C3
Knight takes E3 Knight to C6 by the way
they're still following a game berkich
versus lupulasco who is one of the
compatriots of bognan Daniel Dak and
maybe a training partner as well and up
to this point Bogdan knew what he's
doing he hasn't spent almost any time he
still had 23 minutes and change and
Knight to E4 this is the first move and
he spent 10 minutes on it at this point
he only had 13 minutes on his clock and
as we will see later this is something a
disadvantage that Magnus very wisely
spotted early on Knight to E4 Queen
takes D4 Queen takes D4 Rook takes D4
Knight to g3 at this point Bogdan only
has 10 minutes on his clock Bishop to E6
the position is still completely equal
Rook to D1 C5 B3 Rook to d8 Rook to E1
at this point only three four moves
later Bogdan has five minutes so
unfortunately this was his downfall and
as we will see uh Magnus nicely created
weaknesses
got the weaknesses off the board and won
a very important game the first game
that he wins in this tournament and
let's throw Magnus in it uh what did he
have to say about this game
good question first Victory finally how
does it feel
yeah I was a little bit unexpected
um
I finally got to experience
time travel show which is
[Music]
um
you know
interesting enough
um I just think like I know that he
always spends his time like this but
sometimes you get surprised and then
decisions and that's what happened like
like once he started to get out of
control
yeah he had several poor decisions
yeah I see and today how many
photographs did you give on your way to
come in here because we saw one guy took
selfie with you how does it feel like to
go walking
um Universal
you know there are women people are very
nice so usually like in between games
and such I prefer to keep on my own but
I'm generally happy to oblige after
games yeah and last question which is
interested for everybody like about your
hairstyle is it some kind of bed or
something yeah
yeah thank you
what is the end game for that marvelous
hair of Magnus well only time will tell
uh let's take a look at the standings as
we see after round seven we have Levon
aronian and Jan shishtar Duda on 10
points a piece sharing the lead Wesley
saw an mvl closely behind but one player
that is definitely starting to get close
to those first positions is one Magnus
Carlson exciting games ahead for our
tournament we're going to go on a short
break and we're going to be talking
about what the players would do if they
weren't just players take a look
foreign
[Music]
if you weren't the chess player what
would your profession be and why
if I wasn't a chess player I'd probably
be some kind of engineer yeah it's a
very tricky question because I'm I've
been involved in chess since my uh yeah
very childhood and you know I haven't
really considered like different things
I guess I will just run family business
with
it is really very unfair to
to think what I could have could have
done instead because from a very early
stages
I I've sort of missed out on the rest of
it I could say so whatever Hobbies or
interests I have now it doesn't
necessarily mean that this is what I
would be doing right because from from
your early age
it takes certain direction and yeah I
just really cannot tell and I'll be
curious to know because I think there
are lots of things that couldn't
interest me but yeah in my childhood and
later on as well nothing came close to
chess I guess yeah would be something
um
maybe science related or something like
that it's hard to say exactly but I'm
good that
Matt and the computer so those are my
two favorite subjects but
I'm originally born from the Philippines
so if I wasn't a professional chess
player maybe I wouldn't be living in the
US right now because that's how I got in
that's why I'm trying to play good chess
so if I'm not retiring it
um yeah that's a great question
I would love to do a bunch of things but
I guess I would have zero time for any
of those things
so yeah we would be
we will be in a pickle yeah I guess I
don't know I mean you know the thing is
that I'm always hoping to stop being a
professional just player and then and
start out a career so I guess I would I
would need to answer this question
eventually so we'll see yeah
I would be doing something which is uh
connected with stats because I'm uh I
really like stats like a fantasy or uh
some I know something which is connected
with uh sports like football so I think
this one would be something I would
follow I think something competitive
probably you know in a maybe in full of
sports or in the field of art but I
would you know I would love to put my
energy into creating something
I think I will do some science
or let's say I have very good ability to
calculate hundreds and thousands in just
in mind because my granddad is
math teacher so I have this kind of
talent so I probably would be like that
every day
no um truthfully I have I don't know
like because I have obvious but
I honestly don't see myself
as anything else just player but we'll
find out in the future when I
get pushed away by by some young kids
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the super bet in Warsaw
Poland and these are our standings after
very eventful round seven right we
haven't updated standings now we have a
new co-leader alongside young Christoph
Duda livon aronian as Wesley so it gets
uh ding for a loss right he got defeated
for the first time in this event and we
have Wesleyan mvl chair in third right
and magnus's bag Magnus is back I think
that's the headline yeah Magnus and
Richard Sharon
fifth place right
away tashek also just took his first
defeat in this tournament and with four
points sharing last place
a very very exciting pairings coming up
for this round eight let's see lay the
table for us we have Rapport against
duck tour Romanians playing each other
uh chefchenko against Carlson okay the
lasters there's Magnum all is well in
the world man listens back against giri
okay and Wesley against aronia that's
huge the look of that one too did you
die against MPL those two bottom boards
will be our Marquee matchup and bar nice
start to day three in the Rapids
absolutely yeah sir very interesting
games and Lebon is playing really well
it's a water what a wild card you've got
a wild card yeah he's playing really
good chess I mean he's very very strong
in this format so this is the big test
for him now he's playing Black against
Wesley and Wesley is going to try to to
press him and if he can play solidly
this is a very important game for level
one with the black pieces absolutely
dude that's a big test for Wesley
because he just lost to immediately
recover uh how does a champion bounce
back after a setback like that but Duda
somehow he's navigating some treacherous
Waters he hasn't lost but boy he's been
flirting with danger uh for a number of
these games in this round he's playing
NBL he will have white but uh he's still
on fire after that yeah a little bit you
start to feel NBL and remember mvl one
of the world's great great Blitz players
as is of course Magnus Carlson uh
reigning Champion I believe in Blitz and
Rapid but uh two great games coming up
and also Magnus uh we pulled the viewers
84 said Magnus was going to win a game
and they were correct and they were
correct I joined them by the way one of
the 84 percent and at Kerala we just had
that nice interview with him uh during
our break
um
kind of missed an opportunity a little
bit of insta but now you're playing the
world's number one what goes through
your mind I think he's just happy to be
there like I would be I would be but of
course he will try he knows that Magnus
is going for a win and he might take too
many risks and that's an opportunity for
career exactly you mentioned that Maggie
was going to be playing a two out of the
three games today with the black pieces
he started with black against Daniel he
won
not the test but the black pieces
and Vara what do you think is going on
in Carol's mind and his moment in the
sun if you will absolutely it's a big
game for him and he had chances against
Duda and if he can continue to play well
I think Magnus will give him some
chances I expect Magnus to take some
risk in this game as well who if he
really needs to get another win a clip
in this rapid section to try to get
closer to the leaders so we have Head to
Head between the two players have they
played in Rapid before if they have I
would say it's few and far between
Carol is quite young very very young
yeah
but when you talk about two players who
are very experienced Wily old veterans
look at these two I wouldn't be
surprised if wrap it alone they played a
hundred what do you think come on jump
in quick none no 100 was too much I
overstated the moment I think Bobby and
live on halfway at about 100 games okay
traffic
seven though I think it was 70 yeah the
Bell gets there okay and they are off D4
Knight F6 nimzo Indian with Queen C2
with Queen C2 or E3 Queen C2 you betcha
and now you just have to some of these
variations now see as they go
20 30 minutes because I played this with
black and I always have to be ready for
the sharp lines exactly exactly and as
I'll just bring up the game of Wesley
I've always liked the classical
variation the nimza with Queen C2 I like
the two Bishops uh as white and today
um of our the the
How Deep The variations go it's just
remarkable absolutely and this move
level or level play the move B6 in that
position besides B6 the main move is
actually also to play D5 which is very
very popular in that position with the
idea to take on C4 them to play the move
B6 but this is a main main Theory this
is actually played many many games here
in database so let's take a look goes
back to the 90s I remember I played this
against uh one Anatoly car pop back in
the day please
in 2000 actually in this variation so
step three yeah F3 D5 and uh you have a
few options here E3 is one of the main
moves here you can also take back on D5
in this position so if you play the move
E3 black will just simply play Knight
bd7
you take only five we can enter to this
famous end game 1965 Bishop d8 Knight C3
I analyze this actually a little bit
disposition Knight goes back to D5
and here she have actually a few options
you can play Bishop F2 King F2 is also a
possibility here there are about 23
games play Bishop F2 is the main line
and after C5
white Place E4 if you give white time to
play the move 92 93 then white is
certainly better here but it's it's not
so easy because after 97 you you take on
D4 Bishop D4 Knight C6 you try to put
some pressure still even in this
position lots of theory I'm curious to
see which lines the players are going to
choose to go yeah yeah I I remember C5
and F5 analyzing both by the way I have
to jump to Maggie's game even though I
want to play play my respects to the
tournament co-leader I play Max Lang
attack uh much of my chest childhood
let's put it that way I love these
Gambit positions Knight F6 E5 now
everybody and his brother has played D5
in this position I didn't even know
there was another move I mean I really
didn't 94 Queen E2 I was always told
that this position was simply bad for
black but modern engines rehabilitate
just these ancient lines 96 takes
castles and check this move out B7 B6
like if you look at this position and
you weren't aware of a chess engine
you'd start to be a little bit worried
because they have Pawn First to begin
with but you start to think you know
you're gonna have to play D5 you're
gonna and then you can see like bad
things are happening on E6 your king is
still in the center and stuff like that
but if you didn't you you look at b6s
you can't play like this right can you
open in the center but here we go he's
done it V6 Knight D2 Bishop B7 and I
just go F4 why wait or Knight F3 and
yeah I I
for me this is novel territory uh VAR I
just have I I didn't even know that this
this was playable what let's say the
modern Theory and is are we in theory no
we're not in theory yeah and deposition
looks okay for black actually it's he's
not worse in this position so after
Bishop B7 here Knight Knight F3 can be
played or F4 also
lights F4 F4 yeah one idea here is to
play the move Knight E7 try to bring the
Knight to F5 so because Knight on F5
will threaten to go to E3 and if you
play the move Bishop D3 we can play the
move Knight F5 anyhow because we're not
really afraid of Bishop F5 he takes F5
and we have a very strong Bishop here
this is a really good Bishop on the
light Square so you know it's a it's a
complex position here 94 is a move and
uh you can play the move even Queen E7
you you're probably gonna Castle long in
this position I was just going to ask
that where is black king going yeah so
uh Queen E7
Bishop D2 and black actually even plays
the move H5 here just simply to try to
secure this knight uh on F5 so very
complicated position here some great
stuff yeah speaking of great stuff let's
pay our respects to the tournament uh
co-leaders in this case Duda versus NBL
as we have a Queen's Gambit accepted
with each film has been successfully
playing yes and that will not have been
lost on Duda that Knight F3 and E3 the
traditional ways of meeting Queen's
Gambit accepted uh bulletproof is MBL so
E4 I've always thought that this is the
most testing way of meeting the Queen's
Gambit accepted look at this Knight
takes e5b4 and we had this position in
Bucharest guys exactly exactly and the
players are blitzing their way through
the theory there's one Pawn Anish was
playing this right
exactly and queen C7 hitting the Knight
on C3 as well as the Knight on E5
Knight C4 box 97 Rook A4 we've caught up
with the players
but I don't see a database
I think the move was B6 in that game yes
instead of 19. I'm really excited about
B6 remember right thank you that shakes
off the cobweb B6 Knight C4 though I
think we were looking at that too
weren't we wrong yes yes Knight Knight
C4 and after move an ibd7 I remember
when we were analyzing I mentioned the
move Rook A6 ish with the idea to bring
the Rook 2 C6 that that was another
alternative for white in this position
right do that clearly analyze this um
yeah and he was ready with Rook A4 uh
Jump Right In first of all what's the
novel The second of all the engines
evaluation it's a two Pawn sacrifice as
black uh
you don't
normally see these gambits as black
because after all you're playing a Tempo
down or apply down yes uh looks like the
novelty is to move Knight C4 according
to my database in that one game I see uh
was there was 96 played by white in that
position and also we we have we saw the
move B6 played in Bucharest but let's
take a look at the current position
right so after the move Rook A4 now the
bishop is under attack on before and
black doesn't have too many options
looks like here Bishop C3 is the top
move for Block here A5 is a possibility
also but that uh that's gonna be another
Pawn sacrifice and B takes A6 and Rook
db8 but I'm not sure if black maybe
analyzes deeply with a very strong
computer maybe he can play this position
but at least my engine is showing a big
Advantage here for a while we do have
Bishop takes C3 on the board as you were
showing A5 as an alternative option
and Knight C5 Rook B4 has been playing
yes it looks like we're probably gonna
enter to this variation with the move
Knight D3
now white has to sacrifice the queen
because C4 is hanging and Bishop D3 and
position is very unclear here white has
a bishop Bishop rook and two pawns right
versus a queen but uh Still The King is
in the middle of the board you need
another extra move to castle and a
little bit of time to consolidate this
position if you can manage to do all
that then white will be better here but
black has some Contra play he can play
the move Knight H5 for example try to go
to F4 is one alternative another option
is actually to try to play the move
Knight D7 which is very logical that
gives you options like Knight C5 at some
point so I think it's a it's it's
Dynamic equality in this position
Dynamic equality that's a nice bailout
as a as a well-known chess author
annotator Dynamic equality was was one
way of saying I don't know what the hell
is going on Dynamic equality you got it
what about Wesley's uh game with Lavone
and game end game we just got started
what are you talking here what not
slightly better end game for white okay
and he did go for that whole line with
no he went he didn't take with the knife
he took with the pawn but somehow
coincident still came off yes exactly
there it was 94.
Knight E4 maybe now Anatoly carpath uh
he played Queenie said well not the same
position but he didn't go for the queen
trade against me 94 takes takes you got
to take the bishop Knight E2
I'm happy with white here I've got an
extra Pawn in the center and the bishop
on B7 doesn't make a great impression so
you know you can go H4 G4 King F2 enjoy
your uh uh space Advantage there G4 98
G5 these guys are so good I mean that he
just knows the Night Belongs on D6 and
such structure sorry Nasi you're right
I'm just surprised here so Wesley played
King F2 which is of course natural I
would have taken on age six first
taking on H6 just don't make Black's
King side weaker
I would pause uh because if you have to
play ghgh I'm with you 100 oh you're
saying black doesn't have to take back
I'm thinking G6 I just want to make sure
that uh the last thing I would like to
see is the king going to H7 and taking
on H6 if I don't have a try H5 G5 Rook
G1 F6 I want to see you play F but I do
have Bishop C2 and I will not let your
king go to H7
I'm happy with that
yeah Wise Guy huh yeah that's a good one
that that that does stop me from
from
winning back in a nice way uh my Pawn on
the king side hmm
um but I hear what you're saying G takes
H6 if it provokes gh6 why not do it
Wesley did play the move King eights who
takes takes I'm not unhappy if I'm
Wesley here because
I got the open H file like I'm the first
to play ready to play King to seven
under cage
all right so my knight on E2 needs life
Knight F4 to D3
to E5 this Pawn can be the target yeah
well truthfully really uh I want to put
a knight on F6 that would be right so uh
I'm playing to go Knight to G4 but
that's illegal you know Knight G4 would
be nice so Knight F4 to D3 to E5 to G4
to F6
um
that would be uh the goal uh jump in VAR
uh has Lavon given Wesley too much yes I
think Levon misplayed it a little bit
earlier when he played a move Knight E4
in the opening I think that move was
unnecessary instead he should have just
continued with the normal development
like Knight bd7 Queen E7 and just play
the move C5 and I think position is just
more or less equal here cid4 was a
culprit yes and this end game is
unpleasant
and if we look at the current position
yeah so he can he can start with the
move Knight G3 Knight G3 yes to prevent
Knight F5
where's the Knight going and uh you you
have to play King G7 yes then Rook H6
comes in
uh just a stop Knight F5 yes and now if
you play Roque then there's this very
nice move Knight H5 check uh
I wanted to get to F6 uh I had it in my
dreams I just didn't know how to get it
back on H5 I take on D6 I think it's a
very pleasant end game no questions
about it if I had seen Knight H5 I might
have found myself drawn to the move
Knight G3 Knight G3 uh very
strange but very strange you have to say
this idea it it it's actually quite
beautiful at some point also with the
Knight on G3 you have the option to play
E4 yes that's what I thought you were
angling for actually when you originally
suggested Knight G3 I thought you were
angling for E4 and maybe on a good day
uh putting pressure on the F7
uh let's just jump to the game of Richie
Rapport versus uh Daniel and for Daniel
day one it rained it poured it was
thunder and lightning everything went
wrong day two yeah
and and Happy Days
however he's under real pressure here
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I'm not liking
this for uh Daniel uh whoa
um
these are nasty uh king-sided taxis
I'm I'm actually just wanting to
sacrifice that immediately well not
immediately I was going to go Bishop E2
Bishop takes H5
um don't ask me why but there's not a
lot of King Defenders I want to bring
the Rook over rookie one would be my
move rookie one rookie three rookie one
rookie three Rover uh you're not afraid
of some discoverers discoveries though
can I pretend that I saw that I saw that
yes I just played like with Elon and
Grace uh ignoring the fact that uh yeah
I definitely missed that yeah but I I
was just about to say Bishop E2
okay if you're forced to play E5
I'm still looking at Bishop takes H5
um it looks like Richie has some
promising uh prospects immediately in
mind here VAR uh does he absolutely yeah
I really like his position here and
there's actually a difference if you
start out with the move Rook fe1 here I
kind of like this move okay you're
encouraging the move 94 against Rook ae1
94 is very strong but against Rook F1
there is a difference here so I'll show
you guys yeah so Rook F1 it plays Knight
before you actually take okay now you
take back with uh Queen takes C4 and now
you play the move Queen H4 and now
you're just gonna play on the dark
squares and now you're ready to play the
move Rook ac1 as well here
and it's a very very good compensation
here and you still have problems
developing your pieces for example if
you play the move Bishop D7 looks very
logical I just play the move Rook AC one
attacking the queen and uh 90. next one
is 94. yeah tonight he's gonna land on a
stick like here is already winning for
white wow so and it's it's it's very
uncomfortable to play a position like
this where your most logical move Bishop
D7 is is really bad here so you have to
find some ideas like this to go back and
then we can play the move Rook ac1
Queen d8 and here even this move G4
might be a possibility too because this
would be a very very aggressive way to
play for white but he has Alternatives
as well in the current position after
move H5 there is a move Bishop B3 which
is very nice as well just to eliminate
this Knight D4 idea with a nice
Advantage for white as well so you can
play Rook F1 or just a move Bishop B3
with a nice Advantage nice uh going uh
to the game
pardon me I I just see that uh Richie
played
Alex C1
yes he played Rook C1 Rook ac1 just to
prevent 94. you know that's like uh what
we might call the mysterious Rook move
Rook C1 protecting the bishop on C4 like
what you know like it's an x-ray uh the
vision was he uh gotta say uh Maggie is
amazing uh
he manages to get positions white and
black where he plays he's got play uh
he's upon up at the moment
F4 Queen E7 instead of 97 which we were
looking at with bar yes 97 Knight F5
then H5 right
yeah F4 maybe he's getting a little bit
afraid that with the king and the center
he wanted to evacuate uh quickly uh
Queen E7 Knight of three castles A3
age six I don't I don't say I'm menacing
the move G5 I I'm like Richard Rapport I
just want to have that option for myself
uh H6 B4 King B8 Bishop D3 and again
these are my favorite positions uh Kings
on opposite flanks
the imbalances are chaotic and the
player who comes up with the best plan
wins it's pretty simple you said you
like white tell tell me why
just to me it seems like White's plan is
straightforward okay we just open up the
queen side a B5 A4 A5 Bishop D2 stuff
like that bang bang
even though their plan is G5 it's not
easy to play G5 because I would just win
that pawn right even though I'm opening
up the king side it's not
very easy go on yeah I mean that's
pretty much it and the extra Pawn on D4
I think white can take it whenever they
want to that's yeah I know you can play
B5 Knight takes D4
um I might play the the devil's advocate
for just a moment because uh lots and
lots and lots of times in these
positions in fact all the time it's
about King safety yeah it's just uh you
know who's got the safer cake you might
be happy that your Pawn is on F4 it
might be going to F5 maybe who knows on
a good day you get an anchor Square on
G6 and
your King's a little bit vulnerable
you've got to put your Pawn on F4
secondly uh VAR mentioned you know the
Polish defense you know that Bishop is
menacing on the diagonal okay it may
take you a while you know Bishop E7 Rook
G8 who knows on a good day I get to play
G5 but I do see the night coming
maybe to F5 maybe the bishop goes to you
man black definitely has counter play
coming it's not one-sided by any means
exactly and by the way the move King H1
also just a little indication that the
king needs a little bit more safety a
great uh position VAR for I think
students of of Chess who need these
imbalances and chaotic positions the
training of a difficult position this is
a difficult position for both players
absolutely it's a three result game here
and the move King H1 I'm not very sure
about because I'm always a little bit
cautious putting my king in the diagonal
of the bishop there right Bishop won't
be seven and now here actually Magnus
has a very very good move Queen H5
and after this move now you're almost
ready to play the move G5 now doesn't
that blunder the pawn now it takes yeah
you you you can take one before but in
the same game I think Black is Black is
fine here because black doesn't have any
any weaknesses 94 is the best move to
play after the move Queen H5 and in fact
it's slightly better for black that end
game Knight takes D4 Queen takes E2 and
here you have an option you can take on
C6 and then capture back on it too or if
you capture back with the Knight
immediately black can even play the move
G5 is a possibility to create a counter
play but also you can start out with the
move A5 here first putting pressure on
before and if you play the move B5 then
Knight Will reroute only seven and you
know we know the desired score is to go
to F5 in this position actually black is
slightly better in this position and if
you try to hang on to the before with
the move C3 which which is a logical
move then we see a counter play coming
in with the smooth G5 and if you take on
G5 and 95 will come in a very
comfortable position now for black here
nice I also I like very much what what
Richie Rapport has done he's got in my
opinion these uh quote hanging pawns but
he's really
um
I want to say he's got the space on the
king side and there is a bevy of weak
darks squares around Black's King uh
that is to say Daniel is in my opinion
in a difficult position yeah
a lot of about this position I simply
don't like for black Bishop C2 might
Menace takes but also it's just like you
can just slowly increase your your
positional I think it just has so many
ideas to choose from exactly whether
they're rookie four and Rook C1 uh
Knight can even reroute itself to E5 I
like what Richie is is doing let me just
go to
um let's jump to Wesley's game because
yes he didn't find the Nike three Knight
H5 idea yeah he did what I thought
was was so self
obviously he wants to bring his Knight
to the E5 Square he did it in a strange
way I thought he would have started with
the move Knight F4 and C5 okay that I
find a bit surprising because it does
invite Bishop B3 right
yeah takes in Rook D1 because I don't
think black wants to come into C4
exactly uh takes and uh that was not
gonna take you and just immediately one
immediately yes okay
and yeah if you uh provoke C4 then
that's E4 yeah I guess you're happy with
uh that uh
let's just take a look at the
head-to-head and this is going to be a
veterans uh
the one does have more wins four more
wins guess that about 32 draws are quite
equal I guess Lavon got in the shots
when Wesley was younger right because
Wesley is such a tough player to beat 16
wins against Wesleyan rapid
pretty darn good what's the engine's
eval on this position slightly better
for white slightly and The Rook 81 is a
very good move and in fact you want to
provoke you know you want to force black
to play this move C4 after that I think
uh it's just going to be better for why
you can prepare the move E4 so let's
take a look here uh after Rook 81
another alternative by the way is just
to play the move A5 which looks also
very interesting to try to create some
pressure on this side of the board but
Rook 81 it's very direct now you're
actually threatening to take on C5 in
this position and if a black plays C4
it's it's not a very good move here
because you can even play the move King
G3 here at some point if needed you can
move the Knight play King F4 and then
eventually you will break through in the
center here even if we exchange all the
Rooks white will have a lot of pressure
in this position so for example if you
take if you just want to exchange
this this is actually going to be a very
big Advantage because you would just
move the Knight now I can go to E2
King G7 and we have the king coming in
here King E5 is coming up E4 is trading
you have to play the move F6 and still
an advantage for white here so after the
move C5 I like Wesley's position but
let's take a look at the Duda mvl game
because we have that the queen sacrifice
happened here as we were expecting and
after Knight D3 Queen takes D3 and 97
was played and I was expecting to see
the move canceling here as soon as
possible just to make sure the king is
safe but Duda played the move Bishop D4
first trying to protect C3 and solidify
the position and now uh A5 very
interesting movie five try to open up
the position here and ampasan B takes A6
and now Rook takes A6 and finally uh
White Castle here another alternative I
think here was instead of capturing back
immediately
black could play the move Knight C5 and
try to put pressure on D3
Perhaps Perhaps this could have been a
little bit stronger because now if you
go back we should be two I can't even
capture that Knight takes A6 so but he
played Rook takes A6 castle and now
white white is very safe and he's
getting ready to play the move rook fp1
and let's put three more moves in let's
say H6 Rook FB one and
you can play the move Rook 8 just to
protect your background slightly better
position after Knight B6 90 xb6 Rook B6
here and looks like white can try to
press here but you still have to be
careful their ideas like Queen F4 with
the queen on the border is always a
denture here but engine gives a slightly
better position for Whitefish thank you
uh VAR for that yeah that game between
it looks easier to apply with so many
pieces versus the queen right yeah well
the bishop on D4 in particular makes a
very uh pleasing impression no question
about that I just wanted to jump to
Carol and uh Maggie's game because we
did see that move Queen H5 as advertised
and I was more than curious to guess
Knight takes D4 Queen takes E2 because
there was this moment where you you're
given the opportunity of trading nights
and I take C6 check before recapturing
the bishop and
I wasn't really sure and I was very
curious to see what the Grandmasters
came out with Knight takes E2 A5 please
include the move B5 no thank you let's
keep the tension and D7 D6 B5 now we've
caught up with the players and again I
just feel like this is one of those
um three result games absolutely
anything can happen I think B5 now came
because if Black Knight moves I'm
jumping back Knight D4 okay after Magnus
played D6 E6 became weak right right
well yeah you definitely but there is a
how they do right I could like for
example take take back on E5 you're
certainly not hanging the bishop so you
take back on
um D5 and I'm wondering if I can take
advantage of this by the way the the
king is on is not on G1 I was thinking
of Knight F5
you know one of those things where I'm
trying to exploit that and I was
thinking that if you take take and
Knight takes okay uh if for some reason
I had it in my mind that the King was on
G1 so I had a bishop C5 check uh upon
two Bishops not sure by the way 97 on
the board so we may see this variation
now see your move Knight D4 looks very
compelling could have also taken on a
fight with the Rook instead of the night
right let's try that one let's see
Knight D4 takes takes
and take with the Rook
it's no it's great on D4 no it is great
on D4
um
I want to play C5 but I don't want you
playing on the song Don't You Dare
Bishop C5 Bishop E3 yeah we have couple
moves on the board he did play Knight F5
they're following our line right
once per broadcast right yeah these guys
are good uh so what do you think VAR of
Maggie's uh
Palm sacrifice is it good I think it's
good I think it's good it's uh Andrew
prefers block I I like the idea of
playing G5 which you suggested yeah sir
instead of the move D6 if we go back
just few moves I thought that was also a
very logical move here just just keep
the pawn structure you know more solid
here this this also would have given
really nice Advantage let's move G5 here
but after after the move D6 there are
more Dynamics this B5 is the correct
response against it and let's take a
look at the current position we have
um after
um his playbooks F5 Bishop C5
Bishop E3 Magnus Blitz threatening
threatening to take the palm of the
force so if you play the move Bishop E3
the problem is actually I just play Rook
h e eight and now position is open and
black has two Bishops and also this E5
Pawn is really vulnerable I don't think
you're going to be able to fully uh
secure this Pawn in this position here
so for example E6 is one of the
Alternatives here
and then uh Rook takes D5 could be
played
and after the exchange Bishop D5 you're
going to lose this E6 pawn and uh but
you want to lose it in in that uh
situation that gives you more chances to
exchange pieces but black doesn't even
take it just King C6 King B7 first
so slightly better position here for
Magnus I think he's gonna try to press
here you can try to play the move Bishop
F4 perhaps just try to hang on to the
pawn but then we can see Rook hf8
exchanging the Rooks
and now some pressure on the bishop you
cannot play the move Rook F1 because of
G5 and you have to find the only move
now Knight B6 Rook F7
and again you need this move Bishop G3
very very complicated variations Bishop
takes A3 here looks like white is uh
okay at the very end here there is this
Knight C7 move in this position
wow but you can imagine Carol's
frustration because he's sitting there
saying aren't I playing a good game
didn't I win a pawn aren't I pressing
the world's number one player and the
engine comes back says no dude you're
slightly Bishop B2 so much more time
Magnum says 18 and a half minutes while
Carol's down to eight minutes wow and
Magnus is really trying to squeeze it
this was a really bad move I was about
to say this move would never have
occurred to me same same for me here in
particular there is a very strong move
here for black Rook D5
by the way when you said Rook D5
previously you had said Rook takes D5
because the Rook coming to D5 was so
strong it had to come there with the
capture yeah Rook D5 looks really good
it's one of those moves that you just
kind of rookie one rookie one yeah
rookie one Bishop takes D4 actually it's
a very big Advantage because I think and
and then uh attacking the bishop on
because I didn't even see the beef
and if we compare the Bishops it's very
clear yes
Rook to B5 uh going after your A4 Pawn
wow Bishop B2
um
yeah that moved it I I thought Bishop E3
all the way I thought Bishop F4 makes
sense as well they should be too it
really seems to be hiding
um I like Rook D5 something even okay
maybe it's too elaborate a for uh just
keeping everything
um Frozen on the queen side but I love
the Mover of D5 all right let's jump
again to the game between Yan and mvl
because
that game is so crucial for our
tournament standings and again it's
rooken Bishop versus queen but guess
what I've got two pawns to go with the
rook and Bishop and the Knight pardon me
the bishop on D4 really looks dominant
here
um
me three uh
that I I think this was the moment it's
it's very strange that nvl didn't seize
the the chance to play Knight C5 like
Carpe Diem I mean you want to be able to
play Knight takes A6 with the tempo and
what he's got is I think the worst of
all possible worlds because
well exactly and you know the Rook is is
coming even worse I think the night is
coming to D5 if I could
uh manage to take the Knight on E3 off
the board as well as the bishop on E6 I
love the two Bishops versus the queen
and Knight in that position then I can
get to go Bishop C4 so I see Knight D5
as a really massive positional threat so
does MBL he played the move Queen D6 in
order to protect D5 but I don't light
Black's position at all here VAR and
even well Bishop D3
no maybe that's asking too much but I I
don't like what mvl has done I think so
also I think he misplayed it and now
white has a pretty nice Advantage here
it's like plus one here you can play the
move Rook D1 you can start with uh
Knight D5 immediately yeah I was about
to say 95 I I didn't realize it but I've
got Bishop Jack and Bishop E4 if you try
to take twice on D5 but Rook D1 also
once you see Rook D1 and the fact that
the Knight protects the rook and this is
a a nice Discovery uh VAR sorry to steal
your thunder there but how did the
engine like it uh engine thinks white is
a very big Advantage after the move Rook
D1 yeah at some point even plays the
move Rook B2 back let's say queen C7
just to make sure there's no Contra play
and again getting ready to play that
move 95. yeah put the Knight on D5 and
start pushing the C Pawn here it's just
a two result game here but really good
winning chances here after the move
Knight D5 here nvl needs to play the
move Rook A2 he did not he captured and
G7 G6 he he the the the highly desirable
Queen takes actually runs into a huge
problem Bishop check and now because I'm
threatening the skier Bishop E4 you have
to play F5 and suddenly after Rook B5
it's play on one goal so he did not take
G6 he played G6 and you were talking
about and he played it yeah
uh almost winning Advantage here now for
white and we know if this pound lands on
C5 C6 the game is going to be over so
immediately mvl's hope is just to
somehow set up a blockade against C5 but
I think eventually white should be able
to break through here with uh some
Preparatory moves yeah
no counter play with the queen white
king is completely safe yes
that and there's even a vulnerability of
a rook landing on h8 for amazing you
know black king looks weaker than
Wednesday even though Black's the one
with the coin exactly just let me let me
just throw uh A variation I'm blowing it
I apologies but I just wanted to point
out if you didn't have Queen takes D5 if
you went for Knight takes just the
potential of uh that bishop and a rook
landing on h8 blue boy oh boy so this is
Duda all the way where's Wesley Lavon
and we wow a lot of things have happened
so when we left it Wesley took
immediately by the way he didn't like it
to move he didn't like your move up D1
he did provoke
um
c5c4
and all the Rooks did come off and what
a beautiful night on D4 yeah it's a
thing of beauty but it needs help
E4 takes takes
um
okay uh
is he quickly get is getting his King to
D4 and trying to win C4 Pawn well okay
but I've got counter play don't I this
last move uh Knight B7 is menacing
Knight C5 what happens after Knight C5
maybe I push A5
okay I'm I'm persistent it's nothing
else I'm consistent night uh A6 okay
I'm getting a lifetime membership to my
own club right the Von grubbers uh so
what you're gonna you're gonna give up
uh the a pawn for the C Pawn is that the
big idea Okay jump in bar
um I don't know I mean if if I could get
the king in the game for white maybe
I've got something but it's a timing
yeah I think it's it's it's it's balance
at the end you're gonna probably give up
the a pawn but then you're gonna move
the knights from F3 and put it on D4 and
that's what he's trying to he just
played the move Knight B5 uh it's it's
very concrete uh clearly the King on h8
is out of place right the question is if
level one is going to have time to bring
it in he needs to play a little bit more
accurately I think there is some danger
for him here but with accurate play
should be equality here let's check out
some of the lines here and Lebon has
extra 10 minutes on a clock here six
minutes versus 16. so yes he just played
the move Knight B5 now putting pressure
on A6 okay so Wesley has two options in
this position he can play the move A6
which looks good but also he can just
capture this Knight and now if you take
back you can put the Knight only six and
now putting pressure on the pawn on D5
and you don't have a good way to
activate this bishop and uh this might
be actually a safest way for level to
play and if you play the movie Bishop D1
that will give him time to bring his
King into the game Bishop E2
Knight takes G5 Bishop takes Bishop C4
and uh King F6
and I have the king gets only five I
think block is already playing for a win
here so you have to play the move King
D4 here or King F4 and we can have
Knight F3
King E3 and I can go back to E5 already
once the Knight is only five block is
very safe here so I think this would be
the safe option another alternative is
to play the move A6 in that case I think
we might see the move 96 putting
pressure on C4 on F7 and now Bishop
takes A4
Bishop takes A4
Knight takes A4 now King D4 comes in
protecting the C3 Pawn King G7
and now E5 is one idea to try to
blockade everything not allowing the
move F6 but now there is a move Knight
B2
Knight takes C4 Knight D1
and uh it's gonna be very hard to
advance this this C Pawn here if we go a
couple of more moves here we'll see
Knight B6 uh Knight F2
and uh C4 we have a knight H3 and
capturing the pawn on G5 and Knight Will
land only six and it should be
inequality at the end as well just in
time and let's jump over to Warsaw as
Christian is with a special guest
and
thanks Yasser yes we are indeed with the
13th world champion Gary Casper of Gary
it's a pleasure to have you in
consecutive days here on the broadcast
to do some analysis what did you see in
today's rounds so far
no there's no blood yeah so yesterday
was quite a Droid day and so uh today I
mean not not because they were in Rush
mode but it just happens
either both players play well or both
make mistakes you know it's an equal
number of mistakes in the same the round
that you uh joined us yesterday I think
was probably the most exciting yeah
phenomenal round but
as of today so it is more excitement
because the results uh though it's
against this every every result the size
of the game in chess is the result of a
mistake and uh it was quite appeal to
see how the Act was losing an end game
where I think he had
very I mean very good position against
me yeah
he should have never lost that then
it's amazing maybe put some pressure on
the exactly yes yes so um uh but
otherwise again it was interesting so
the the mvl played a very very good game
again so very interesting game so uh and
uh
is again I'm not sure that still gets
this maybe though other ways but still
to see his Knight moving across the
board from B5 to G6 B5 A3 C2 E1 every H4
G6 yeah
it was quite impressive let's take a
look at that is Magnus is back in
business yeah yeah and certainly is yeah
and he's playing all the Romanians today
he's it's Magnus versus two years yes
yes no no three three oh yes
um yeah
scored a important Victory with the
black pieces now again with the black
pieces has a slight Advantage this is
looking good for magnets
how practical it is to actually get the
victory here given that maybe after
Bishop D4 Bishop D4
City for some uh up Bishop D4 C takes D4
maybe later in the game
yeah okay I think we should be we should
be more generous with us
I mean white still has an extra black
still had extra porn also white that's
nice it does all right no of course his
plus Bishop D6 now yeah and then and
then he probably put Bishop on D5 D5
that's what I would yeah suggest five
maybe
he hasn't played um
I'm just trying to get the opposite
color of visuals and like exactly you're
right yes
I'm hunting foreign
yes but maybe you can still continue
right something like this bishop C5 and
then if you take maybe you will look at
it
is this getting dangerous for your king
um
some uh like Europe was the wrong yeah
that's this wrong position
yeah yeah but I I can I can can I just
place it for you yes and probably I put
my rock on it too
no but I give Chuck and Bishop Bishop
take on C4 you take on D6 E7 no I'm not
I'm not doing well there
yeah no this is this is still playable
we'll see so this is
so we have we have something different
we have Rook to F fade not Bishop D6 so
he's going for the tracks on the back
Rank and Rook to F5
this is the current position
how can I get to that point on E6
actually um
[Music]
I think that's forces that's worse yeah
but how easy is this angry hello
I don't know
but you king the king is a bit far
yeah but what happened with the bishop
of six that's a good question yeah
who's who's first right oh
okay yep
you don't take the pony try to create a
password
yeah this is just okay okay fine so the
skills go back so I I I I I don't have
to exchange Bishops
Knight H6 this is what we have Bishop D5
now yes
still not easy
still not easy for either player
actually
black should have the easier game though
right
he played King d8 by the way
or not their moves
okay is it good or bad
of course maybe maybe bad but I mean
just can you play that G8 though
yes E7 chip
that's the draw yeah still alive that's
a nice one yeah yes Paul let's just show
it King D7 or King here is Knight F6 so
you have to take and this is the
opposite color of the Japan game yeah
probably draw yeah you know you know wow
he played on the board let's see yeah
that's
it's Bishop defy the only move can I
look if you go King here to play C4 then
your Bishop is trapped there can I go
here ah Bishop
oh
that's interesting ah
see it
and we can see here real is looking
around maybe relaxed a bit prematurely
uh this one has ended the let's do that
versus mvl and do they actually want to
do one yes one quite quite handle him
quite handily yeah yeah he gave a queen
but uh too many too many pieces and
pulls yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is ups and downs I played great
game against all and then that's his
style collapse that's his style yeah so
what's happening this game just I just I
didn't see the opening
[Music]
told me because I asked him about this
about the open he said oh I forgot my
analysis so he came with it
yeah he came with some analysis this
queen sacrifice yeah very nice maybe
objectively you know black is fine but
from a practical perspective
exactly
wow
he's finding All the Right Moves
keeping the pressure on two minutes 30
seconds for kid real
getting down and that's something that
Magnus has been doing great at this
tournament he's so fast
Bishop C1
E6 another six and the bishop is trapped
okay yes ah no no no no no yes Bishop C1
that's a nice trick now Bishop C1
yes he played it that's a nice trick
maybe he's gonna fall for it
okay
yeah
two first
and try to hide my Bishop on E1 all
right no but H4 it gets trapped yes it
is
whatever so this is the
so what if I try to take away your E4
Square
yeah but then how are you going to win
the pool king of seven a king of silver
the Knight is okay so I think F7 doesn't
actually threaten anything
you have seven I have to go Bishop D7
Bishop D3 and maybe taking the maybe you
want to take this point yeah D5 yes
interesting
yes
can we go Bishop G5 A3
and there's no discovery check software
yeah if I lose the A3 Pawn he played
this one
he's good
so okay really we should probably start
moving yes
but then let's attack
but it still is the
it's
um
yeah I just want no I won't just move my
camera
okay clean usually
and now finally I have the G1 Square so
maybe I can attack it
yeah maybe but I I could have actually
it was with some words you know where
your Bishop goes away so maybe I should
go King H2 instead of here
G4 G4 G4 yeah G4 Bishop D3 knocking H2
yes
let's say take Knight of 694.
so this is the key this is the key yes I
got your Bishop yeah
so that's the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
so King H2O D6 Check Yes but if you see
this six chat maybe you can play after
G4 I can go Bishop B6
yes so yes
okay G4 yeah that's a that's a tricky
move
H4 probably has to be played you have to
create something good H4 but just to
wait H okay let's go Bishop
D3 that's do the same thing
that we've been doing
trying to go hunt that B5 Pawn
I think every time you play G4 I go I
attack your line yes yes
no this is another six check 94.
Okay so
king of seven at least this is going to
gain your Tempo Knight of six yes
and when I take on B5 E8 I take with a
bishop
Knight F6 he played okay that's
that's he's going for the Knight on D5
what's this C4
you do have Bish before which is kind of
annoying but even if you wait that's
actually pretty bad why
because you're losing the A3 I think
yeah okay but maybe still my best chance
and take a look at the times right now
okay real 29 seconds against nine
minutes
I think it's yeah the back muscles you
know finds resources resources yes yes
but he's fighting killer so give him
credit of course of course
I don't know fighting opening as well
yeah the scotch okay
take this tool so how are we looking
after this
we don't want my choice you have to take
and then we should be two years yes
foreign
games once again
pulleys
the Bishops against the Knight is a win
right yeah but it's not just two minutes
and a lot of parts it's one point it's
still left so it's not just yeah that's
the problem how do I get rid of G6 yes
okay Magnus is taking a thing
right now
maybe it's not clear Bishop C5 or 394
46.
what's the latest yes
this phone is alive yes so what's this
Pawn is
can you get to it though can you
exchange it somehow
listening before actually
a bit audio
this is all he wants to meet Bish before
I think with King C5
he takes you for it
yes okay English perform King C5
Bishop C7 King takes C4 but Knight takes
B6 B3
King takes B5 working takes B5
okay or or they're following the line
Knight takes B6 King takes B5 he has to
take away four now
which he did
okay so I have this Bishop D6 now yeah
that's the point is no he didn't defend
that corner he's trying to use the king
no what do you do we better defend the
pawns it pulls up 46 yeah
but let's see this is the it's the
um
I don't know how you can exchange the
pawn but but possibly it is I would love
to get my Bishop on G5 but that's
unfortunately that's how it's just G4
that industry h4h5 yes yeah
what's timing now that's how other games
32 seconds I I suspect this game will
last yes a few more moves so that's the
let's see if there is anything super
interesting
um bogdon is doing well
Bogan against Richie rapport Battle of
the Romanians yeah he's definitely doing
well yes yes
still his usual
patented time travel but uh
30 seconds against three minutes but a
better position
pretty much unusable if that's a word
position
yeah
in 96 now since the position was good
right B5 Knight C3
no options or options why not
A2 is
calling someone yeah yeah no it's
looking good maybe maybe some chances
for for both Dan to get back on 50 for
the day no you don't need rules three
you played it
yes 96 is on the board
it's looking good
both of them might take it okay look for
1940 94 and
yeah that's it yeah
okay he played Rook B2
but still the same thing
94.93
King E1 only move
let's see one
94 is on the board
this is pretty much sure but you don't
have to oh yeah
Knight C3 Knight C1
trying to understand what he's looking
for I wrote to A4 just
now he's going to bring the kick
why is this way
King F3
yeah this is an end game
let's see if Magnus made any progress
yes he did
he did okay he did
block the pulls
yes Bishop D7 he blocked the polls
King G3
and then G5 yes yeah now G5 no do you
want to play G5 H4 maybe yeah
at least not yet yeah no no no G5 page
four yeah
I'm not
this I don't have to
and the one player that's struggling
Geary is about to get his first Victory
against uh rather's love
checkmating who first is the question on
the second rank I think the answer is
pretty obvious
it's black yes first
okay perfect
escapes
and you get checkmated yeah no it's
looking good for Geary
um he's been having a rough event so far
minus three I mean that's yeah I don't
think I've ever seen an audition in such
a bad shape what's happening
I have no idea so let's see definitely
the moves he made they were very
unimpressive yeah yeah so
about to look we all are entitled for
our good and bad moments of course of
course well you won he he won very nice
the game has
finished Magnus is basically putting the
final touches
okay but what if I go
that's what that's what he wants to do
yeah and then write h4h5 yes who's first
right so let's oh he played King C5
King E5
not Bishop aha so he wants to go Bishop
six yeah but that's Bishop CA that's not
good this this would be a nice way
he will play Mission before yeah
no but here at the point Bishop A6 of
course
the only chance here should be six
there was a Chanel it was still a chance
here
yeah the H4 H5 is this in English
that's the that's
okay so let's say go maybe Michael's had
to like give you a check I push you back
too
now how do I stop you oh there's so much
garbage B6 you go back to F3 yeah
maybe I can go from behind
but still but if you need to begin with
you too right
Maybe
do you yeah Chad can give to F2 yeah
ah but now I go before
I kick your Bishop out
yeah
it was a good try
that's a good try he's still thinking he
hasn't played a game not moved yet
but
they are repeating
against uh Richie
okay that's a good save for Richie
and Levon
he's been impressing so far the wild
card but he is really doing well in this
event
he had big Advantage at one point I
believe
a little no soil Advantage but so had
some some good position
and I think earlier on you
know so I I know I know this position I
know it's opening wow interesting
yeah here is yeah that's that's I
analyze it's ages ago was this this
bishop b594 this this end game it's lady
five years ago
two miles but I just remembered this
year that's in this year 1940s yeah yeah
yeah I mean yeah he uh
you know it's it pays off to know your
classics
that's for sure
um and right now it just seems like kind
of fizzled into some sort of a draw yeah
yeah all right we need to stay with
Magnus though yeah
he's putting the finishing touches yeah
okay but how do you make progress
you give me a check I go to F6 how do
you make process
d78
maybe that's the way yeah
there you go G5 at any point
yeah probably not
and that's another uh draw and indeed
this is the final game of the realm
kiril versus Magnus King C6
yep following your prescriptions
yeah
yeah of course
37 now
he hasn't played it yet but
that seems to be the natural progression
you should be successful
an H1
yes yeah
yeah
so you still have to be slightly careful
but yeah what is this is a typical
Magnus
typical magnets
he hasn't yet
he he has not yet but that's something
that he does well he he speeds in inches
so I'll give you a check
well
these six you have to go back right
before King D5 it should be someone King
D4 King is six okay
but no this is I don't think this is
good enough
by the way he did not play King D7 no
but that's not that's not take Taking E5
it's all right
H5 G5 H6
very nice very nice very nice yeah
that's a nice calculation
one Temple once again one Temple
and that's why maybe King D7 no he
played this page wait
already
B7 now 27 is coming yeah that's it
is it that's it no that's the king king
is there so what's this too
yeah H4 yeah
this king is there now
you can we can exchange pools
okay how do I get to your points but now
maybe you should be seven
and then
H4 Bishop C1 yeah
Bishop
is that one yeah yeah
now I catch it but I catch it with it
he finished the job
C7
5 though
you know you're having a bad tournament
and then you start winning this type of
games grinding games that give you great
satisfaction
how much boost in confidence do you get
from that I don't know I think that's
that's not unusual for maggots yeah yeah
to
uh
come back so let's see but let's say
that these young opponents remain
importance are not most
most impressive damn game are giving him
chances yeah manage he managed
themselves so the good thing is he's
back in the game it's definitely this is
makes the tournament more exciting yeah
absolutely actually he's going to be if
I'm not mistaken maybe just
three points away
or maybe even best two points away from
the lead
that's one game by the way he still
won't move the game was writing his
report and and then tomorrow enough with
18 rounds in the next two days Blitz
Blitz Blitz here that's it
it was probably some chances that you
could better job but and there it is the
resignation
wow wow Jerry thank you for joining us
okay always a pleasure to have you and a
great exciting games guys back to you in
this video thank you Gary thank you
Christian and it's one of those 60
percenters once again Nasi as we have
seen three decisive games Magnus
grinding it down two out of two with
black pieces black pieces both games is
he gonna go and make a trifecta well
round nine is coming up before we go to
round nine we had an interview with the
Polish Chess Federation president and
the maker of the first move radislav but
I missed his last name uh we'll be right
back after this break
foreign
the president of the Polish Chess
Federation Radisson first of all welcome
back to the show tell us a bit about
this uh surge of popularity in Polish uh
chess how did you see this from the
inside well uh trust in Poland were
always very popular I remember
times in our history before the war do
interest olympiading Warsaw 1935 when
every ticket was sold out it was about
five thousand tickets so this is no
surprise to me that we see crowds of
people here in the theater watching the
games chess is extremely popular in
Poland we estimate we have millions of
people playing chess but in the
Federation there is 125
000 registered players and I think a
very important is to impact the Young
Generation do you see the numbers of
young people picking up chess yes this
is the numbers are growing and there are
uh giant I believe the main reason is
anxious to do the Superstar world-class
Superstar and all these young uh young
Juniors they want to
um to be like him and this is this is
very very well something we never had
after the war we we didn't have such a
player this is a great impact and we
have exactly 55 000 registered juniors
in the Federation and he's not the only
one uh radoslav voitage is an incredible
example as well and what a better way to
open up the tournament than to defeat
the world champion in the Polish opening
how did you leave that moment
I was watching the game but I think that
Magnus went too far he wanted probably
to make a show and not a disrespect
maybe but somehow he
he might have believed that rather is
maybe not the best player in the world
so he can play polish opening and and
but I was very
I was how to say it's a gamble right
yeah
europocal poker player as well former
poker yes a former poker player when I
became president of the Federation I
stopped playing poker professionally I
played in European Poker Tour 15 years
ago yeah I see Magnus cousins playing in
Montague was playing in Monte Carlo uh
well I like it very much I published it
on my chess my my fan page of my present
of the preparation of my own well I
think he's doing a very good thing what
is there's a very um for me it is very
important that such a superstar like
Magnus also plays poker like me in the
western where this is normal but
sometimes in Poland not the government
is not so kidney with legalizing the
gambling but yeah I don't think maybe as
you know in Poland we're talking about
poker it's uh no it's not like in the
United States with the richest normal
but Poland it is right but we see a lot
of uh incredible chess tournaments and
not only this one you guys organize the
world rapid and Blitz here not so long
ago what are the plans for the future
well the plans we are organizing a woman
Team Championship world team
championship women in September really
because 5 to 12 of September and we are
expecting the best
teams from the world to be there and I I
already know this will be another great
tournament in Poland after this
important award Blitz and Rapid in
National Stadium in 2021 now there will
be also a woman Team Championship but
also we organize disabled World
Championship disabled in September and
also seniors European seniors in
in sorry in August and in July so there
are a lot of
International tournaments chess in
Poland in every month runs love you have
a lot of work ahead of yourself we'll
let you go back to the games enjoy the
games thank you very much for all your
support okay
[Music]
thank you
for the first time since 2020 the
world's best female chess players
converged in the chess capital of
America St Louis Missouri for the Third
Edition of the Karens cup beginning June
3rd players will compete for a 180 000
prize fund
this tournament features 10 of the top
female chess players in the world
including returning Champion humpy
koneru along with top-rated American
Irina Crush
it's one of the most decisive classical
tournaments in chess that you won't want
to miss
catch all the action on the Saint Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch channels
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everyone to our live
coverage the rapid chess is really
living up to its reputation here are our
standings right now for the first time I
believe we have a soul leader young
Christian the big win against NBL it was
important wasn't it and then close the
following in clear second and clear
third two Americans live on Iranian and
Wesley South hey hey hey hey world
number one Magnus Carlson catching up
with nine points do it a trifecta on the
last day of Rapids who knows Magnus
Carlson MPL chair in fourth place the
game coming up between
uh let's take a look at the pairings
right we have mvl planchevchenko Iranian
against that is the pairing I wanted to
say that is just so huge Gary again so
can Anish play spoiler theek against boy
tashek and here it comes Carlson again
can I hear a sweep the Romanians have
lost two in a row in the lifetime
headaches like he has a good chance
since he has five wins against Richard
was about to say that is very very
impressive I wouldn't have guessed that
five wins no losses two draws and after
two rounds of our what has impressed you
definitely Magnus is very impressive
also I like how Levon is playing so far
very solid never really been in big
serious trouble and do that of course
that was a very very nice win against
mvl but I think Magnus is getting his
Norm now and it's very very dangerous
you know once he gets his form in Blitz
especially he's just so intuitive it's
going to be very very difficult to stop
album so I think we could have a race in
this tournament yeah he's number one for
a reason yes and uh you know you never
count them out he came in today minus
one he didn't win a single game now he
just scored Four Points thanks to the
double scoring system weighted in the
Rapids if he can do it again he will
have a plus four going into the blitz
where he's really dominant and here is
the schedule for
coming up starting tomorrow we'll have
the blitz just for two days that will
play 18 rounds of Blitz each uh Blitz
game is worth 1.9 points up for grabs
tomorrow nine points up for grabs on
Thursday and Duda was probably looking
behind him and saying oh somebody
stopped this guy as we see our format we
have a 10 play around Robin and time
control in Rapid is 25 minutes with 10
second increment in Blitz it will be
five minutes with two second increment
and as yes just mentioned in the rapid
they have two points for win and one for
a draw while in Blitz they'll go to
regular scoring system one for a win and
half for a drop
right and talk to us about Lavon aroni
and his place so far versus Duda bar
what are you expecting levonne with the
white pieces I think he's going to try
to push he's got the white pieces and if
he can win this game he's going to have
the sole lead after the rapid Porsche
and Lebon is also extremely strong in a
bliss format so I think he will take his
chances I don't think he'll take so much
risk because you definitely don't want
to lose the guy who is a point ahead of
you because then the Gap will be three
points right so definitely he will push
but if he doesn't get chances I think
draw is okay it's only one point
difference with 18 Blitz Games to go
anything can happen so very impressed by
11 so far yeah as we see Leonard Otis
our official photographer the man with
the blue hair
he is an amazing photographer he really
is exactly do go to his site you will
see thousands of photos taken over the
many years that Leonard has traveled the
world yes always captures true raw
emotions on the players faces exactly is
due to a tournament leader getting into
the Zone the mindset that you need both
players here Anish Gary again a very
unsuccessful first two days for Anish
but he will be
pleased as you possibly can be with this
last win and how do they stack up
against one another so many games 43
draws but Wesley has slight Advantage
with three more wins than Anish
who who did Wesley just play it was
Lavon because it was 41. yes
41 versus 42 draws wow
um and again a spoiler alert as Anish
might just be back coming into form as
this is going to be our Marquee matchup
first place up for grabs in the Rapids
and we've seen that numerous times
um VAR that in these rapid and Blitz
oftentimes the player who wins not
unsurprisingly is the player who won the
rapid absolutely so many times the
leader after this rapid portion wins the
overall yeah and that two point it
counts for a lot and uh so that's why
it's very very big game uh Lebon versus
Buddha right now
E4 or D4 take your pics
well somebody has to be the odd man out
I'm gonna go with C4 C4 English opening
what should we expect from Carlson
Robert opening
those two lights
Bishop A3 uh yeah G3 uh I don't think
we're gonna see a birds but I'm not
gonna rule it out you can't rule
anything out in this game you know it's
funny that one B4 is the orangutan and
one B5 is the Polish opening he will be
happy he played your opening before but
I picked the wrong guy
Lavon
and we have a potentially open Sicilian
now yes we do uh D4 Knight takes uh
sorry this is mvl's game oh sorry we
have pulled up in the boss game we have
uh Petrov
my my bad I I had the wrong game
yeah we have Petrov without D4 with
Bishop D3 again the white player is just
searching desperately for an advantage
and I remember uh Lavon
uh laughing at himself when he was
playing you know these types of moves
Bishop to D3 Bishop F1 you know and he
was praising himself you know look at my
play yeah sir aren't you impressed he
put my Bishop back on its own what is
your response or are you impressed great
great great great great my students were
just delighted with you we should jump
to a magnus's game we do have a surprise
and second move from Richie it might
transpose to something more traditional
traditional but for the moment be six
second move yeah yeah a little bit uh a
little bit off the the beaten pad the
ep7 E6 uh G3 Magnus searching his
database like what can I get that's a
little bit offbeat Knight C3 uh
intriguing yeah
and what do we have in Anish giri Wesley
game we have ninto
shivar has some news for us
Jump Right In before yeah we have a very
sharp opening here guys Sicilian dragon
and very very theoretical line here so
chefchenko is still I think looking for
that one win here and he's trying to
play a very sharp line here so let's
let's take a look at this uh uh Theory
right now in this game so at the moment
Bishop C4 is played and we have a 40 47
games in the database in this position
and here Queen C7 is the main move here
to move the queen away and white usually
plays the move G4 try to control the F5
square and discourage the move F5 and
here uh Rook ed88 could be played
pulling The Rook on a d file and now
some Discovery attacks coming up against
the queen and white can play the move
Queen F2 now removing the queen from D2
and also now putting pressure on this
diagonal so still a lot of games played
in this position Knight F4 could be
played Bishop takes E6 and Knight takes
E6
and looks like a little bit of an
advantage here you can remove the move
the bishop back here on E3 it's one
option another alternative would be to
try to play G5 and just try to fix this
F6 Square so still some Theory involved
but I like this opening choice
I remember Sergey kudrin playing these
um Dragon uh variations and he would
play them like a religion and people
would really really really prepare hard
for him but he he held a lot of games
there I'm just looking at the
theoretical dispute that's going on
between Anish and Wesleyan it's sort of
like bang bang bang bang who can play
faster uh than whom and I don't even
know the state of theory here but
clearly we're still in both players
preparation so my eyes I mean this
really feels like a very dangerous
position for for black and I I wouldn't
enter this position as black without a
very firm uh knowledge and look at look
look at how quick actually Guys Wesley
had this position as white against ding
no so he is definitely familiar with
this position wow but how long ago was
it is it recent against dink um
2020. okay 2020.
this guy's memories you know yeah and I
must say by the way I was I was
listening to a podcast uh c squared
podcast Christian and uh Bobby and they
were talking about their chess engines
and how they are renting Cloud engines
because the valuations keep changing
from year to year with I with each
alliteration of their engines and you
know what worked two years ago the the
top engine would say equal now top
engine say no longer equal so oftentimes
you have to update your prep of our
absolutely as a coach you're aware of
these dangers yeah yes we're doing the
same thing we rent this Cloud engines
and they're they're extremely extremely
strong and give you really good depth of
the position very clearly like for
example this position is very very sharp
and deeper you analyze you might have
chances here and looks like this bishop
E3 move came as a little surprise for
Wesley and he's trying to figure out
what to do he can take on F5 here Queen
takes F5 and play the move Queen G6
giving the pawn back and uh played this
position that's that's one alternative
another option he has here he can play
immediately without taking on F5 to move
Queen G7
because you need to you need to move
that Queen from H6 so to be able to
protect your Pawn with H6 here so these
are his options basically in this
position Queen G7 immediately or take on
F5 so the evaluation is
it's very slightly better for white but
once again it depends how deeply you
analyze this position I think with the
Deep analysis is probably going to end
up being equality at the end but uh
there might be some traps on the way so
I think Anish is you know well prepared
for this okay we'll keep an eye on that
where would you like to take this I
think we should check mbl's game since
we have a sicilian Dragon our favorite
um
he's looking to come back bounce back so
right Queen F2 on the board not these G4
and I'm trying to think it was Magnus
versus gawaine Jones where where Magnus
blundered a piece
it was it was great it was from a Tata
steel where it was something like this
you can imagine a G3
H6 and somehow came F5 in this Knight on
e4 got trapped wow and Magnus lost a
piece and won the game it was like wow
it was like what I mean yeah
that was amazing uh Lavon versus Jan uh
once again our two tournament leaders
let's see what we've got okay it was
this Petrov with Bishop F1 the things
have gotten a little interesting kind of
shades of MBL versus Wesley so as uh
isolated Queen Pawn from the Petra
remember uh Knight E5 and queen F3 was
the winning prescription for mvl
oops I think Bishop C2 is a new move
yeah what was the uh previously played I
say one game in the database Christian
has played this with whites yes okay I
can imagine Bishop G5
even even something to be suggested for
Queen D3 perhaps uh Bishop C2 novelty
jump in VAR
um what what did the statistics tell us
about this all-important game yeah
Bishop C2 is the new move it's possible
that Levon analyzed this uh move uh the
main move in that position instead is
Bishop G5 just a logical move to develop
the bishop and connect your Rooks but
let's take a look how black can now play
after this new move Bishop C2 so here
you have a few different options but
looks like you need to move your Bishop
here so you have to move Bishop D6
and try to exchange the Rooks and more
pieces you trade it's less likely you're
going to be under a very strong attack
here so Bishop G5 comes in and once the
bishop is on G5 you can play the move
Bishop E6 because because you no longer
have to worry about the move Knight G5
and now we can see something like Queen
D2 plate Queen uh D7 and then rookie one
rookette and I think it's very solid for
black I'm I don't see any any problems
for him there is this move 95 will come
in but you never take only five in this
position once the Knight is there you
simply Retreat the queen on C7 or on C8
here in fact I like to go see it at some
point just keep an eye on some Bishop H3
tactics so engine thinks black is
absolutely fine in this position and
gives all zeros at the moment all right
and I noticed in the west Anish Gary
Wesley so again Wesley chose to return
the G5 Pawn he played that whole
sequence with Bishop F5 and queen G6 and
they're in this ending almost
perforce uh rook and Bishop versus rook
and knight uh we saw Magnus grind down
Daniel dioc earlier uh today in these
endings will will
um Anish be successful I think White's
gonna try to do that I think so but uh
well uh it's harder than with Wesley
let's look at magnus's game because they
have
I made a lot of moves rich
Richie okay let's go when we left it it
was just this early B6 uh caught your
eye D4 G6 G3 sorry and they did
transpose into a very conventional uh
Queen's Indian defense
h2h4 E2 E4 Bishop H3 it it's nice when
you're when you have this huge Center
but it's all on light squares and you
have a passive Bishop on E2 which is
crying it's not crying uh Bishop is
actually very decently he's just going
to Castle along yep yeah so long and
Shuffle his pieces for a little bit play
for the break F4 or if the Queens come
off the board
play for a long term advantage on the
queen side it's just space at the moment
no weaknesses is in Black's camp and you
have to decide what you're going to do
with white playing for F4 playing for B4
and C5 a big strategic battle in store
uh a game we're probably not going to
see too much of because of their
position on the score table is between
Daniel
dioc and radislav
this came from
um yeah it was like a queen takes D4
right and queen E3
I never understood what it was that the
wife before no I found exciting about
Queen takes D4 but the
well it looks like quite a lot of theory
right right yeah in this case uh it
doesn't look like white is necessarily
worse sometimes I've seen white get
worse after Queen takes D4 uh intriguing
uh position with play three result
possibility going on here and again back
to Levon because Bishop C2 I know it
started as Petra yeah it transposed to
there's so many positions you can get
with the isolated D4 Pawn with the first
most D4 right right which kind of
reminds me of some nimso and Queen's
Gambit accepted or in slav even
C7 C6 yeah you're right it looks very
very very transpositional
um but as uh Vara was saying uh solid
Bishop G5 uh as long as the knights on
D5 I think black's good okay well uh
here the question is should you be
playing Bishop E6 because this pin
if it was white to move I would be a
little bit
concerned Knight takes D5 you'd have to
probably take with the pawn and then I I
I'm a little yeah I'm a little bit
uncomfortable there all right
um again Wesley Anish sorry
um they've been playing very very very
quickly I suspect we're very much in
Wesley's
um
kitchen uh it's still in his book what
do the engines eval say here VAR nothing
nothing engine shows very slightly
better for why there are no more games
in a database here right so what Wesley
is trying to do he wants to play Rook
fd8 B6 Knight A5 and just try to get his
pieces more active right one thing he
needs to watch out all the time in this
position is if white somehow plays the
move C4 and exchange the C3 pound for
the D5 Pawn then it's gonna have a
long-term Advantage okay so that's
something that he needs he needs to
watch out Rook B1 is just played in this
position now putting pressure on B7 and
B6 very logical move and Rook fd1 is one
idea that comes to mind here to put
pressure on D5 and now he's going to
play Rook fd8 and here I think it's just
it's a balanced position because there
will be some Contra play against the C3
Pawn uh White can start with the move
let's say even A4 at some point if there
is an opportunity to play the move A5
and uh if you play Knight A5 The Rook
goes on D3
black can play Knight C4 activating the
Knight and now white will put the bishop
on D4 in this position
at some point white would like to play
the move H4 H5 Advanced the spawn so
oftentimes we see this idea here H5
suggested by engine the idea is just to
exchange this weak Pawn against the G4
pawn and if you capture here always we
have a move Rook h8 for example then
capture back with the Rook so overall I
think it's it's around equal here we
will see some maneuvering uh
moves here but I think just about equal
here makes sense uh that uh
it's about even and you're right that's
gonna be a long game it sure feels like
it's going to be a long game you asked a
question will Magnus Castle long and
well guess what he sure did castles long
and uh Bishop
A6 very concrete move um so what's the
idea
indeed uh first of all I other than
you're just attacking the pawn but it
looks a little bit strange because once
you play Bishop A6 maybe your desired
future breaks of B5
are difficult b2b3 King B2 very
suggestive Queen E2 is played by Magnus
basically x-raying B5 making it that
much uh harder for black to play
you know I'm expecting that this bishop
was is going to go back frankly and then
you're going to go A6 and Knight C5 and
stuff like that so
I'm not a fan of Bishop A6 and boy I'm
not a fan of this movie either I think
this is a bad move which is still
planning to go Bishop C8 next uh well
okay uh oh you want to play beef oh I'm
very very happy to play B4 I think you
have to play Knight to D7 now uh a lot
of the times when I'm white it looks a
little strange that I've Advanced my
Pawns in front of my king but thanks to
my space and Knight B3 my king is
actually safe even with an advanced uh
structure Magnus did not push before he
did not he can't be one okay he he kept
it steady I have King B1 and Bishop C8
on the board okay so the question is
would the move Bishop A6 the queen has
gone from D2 to E2 and the natural
question is is it better on D2 or is it
better on E2 it seems to me it's better
than me too maybe even better now
because I think that the Knight on F3 is
misplaced I would like to play F4 right
so I'm giving myself an option we have a
couple more moves on the board yes
Knight went to E1 okay probably going to
D3 eventually I'm
I'm uh
uh for for me the primary squares for
Knights are C6 F6 yeah versus C3 and F3
for black so for sure when the Knight
goes to C2 you're gonna have to play A5
you do not I repeat want to deal with a
knight on C6 that's just a it's it's a
great Square Richie played Queen G4
provoking F3 I'm guessing
uh
uh spidey sense alert uh can I take that
and maybe go after the G4 Pawn can you
play F5 wait a minute Spidey alert sense
uh what's happening VAR if I trade
queens and play Knight C2
uh yeah we can check that but I think F3
is even very strong also just play F3
immediately because Queen takes G3 you
play B4 ah and then you go Knight D3
with idea Rook dg1 just simply trapping
the coin that's nice sorry I if for some
reason uh I always thought I had F4 as
an escape but with inclusion of B4 yes
if you take on G40 you actually lose
some of your advantage so I think Buck
is going to be able to play the move F5
very quickly so Queen G4 H takes G4 and
if you play Knight C2
is forced
and at Knight E3 he's gonna play this
move Rook H5 to protect this F5 enter
five it's close close to equality at
this position
is that right
um just a second sorry sorry for wanting
to play The Devil's Advocate here for a
moment because the position I strikes me
is incredibly forcing right so
uh if I play B4
and let's say you go Knight D7 just
cooperate for just a moment and I play
Rook F1
so I want to play the move F3 and I want
to try to isolate king of seven King G6
okay okay we're we're together
give me the pawn 36 gift made upon
oh I see G4 coming
you might also recognize that the Knight
could potentially especially I mean
after the move Rook f8 uh I might be
menacing uh Knight B5 in the future uh
again Queen G4
it looks very attractive Queen G4 Queen
takes G4 I was just trying to grab upon
and by the way uh big big changes in
magnus's tournament uh from the first
two days to today starting with a zero
then a lot of draws and now two wins in
a row wow I mean he's number one in the
world and World rapid Champion I mean he
abdicated this classical title he didn't
abdicate his rapid uh World title Queen
G4 F3 do you think that Richie
realized when he played the move Queen
G4 he was provoking F3 bar I think he
probably missed it because I think he's
losing a Tempo here and now losing time
yeah losing time and now 93 comes in and
now Knight P4 Knight C6 is a threat
correct I would be worried to allow this
Knight to get on C6 because there is no
way to remove it after so you have two
options you either you play the move A5
to make sure the Knight doesn't get on
C6 or you have to take on D3 here
um my understanding is A5 Knight takes
if you play B B takes remember looking
at these Soviet championship games it's
lost it's like it it's strategically
lost and it's really funny why the
reason is it's this Rook D3 to B3 and
the pawn on A5 which you think is kind
of safe suddenly becomes incredibly
vulnerable you never really want to play
C6 which gives up the defy screen right
so you you end up having to take with
the d-pawn and then you're playing
literally you know F4 is very strong now
yeah with this very bad Bishop so uh I
see Knight D3 as coming with a real
oomph for white uh Richie in trouble
yeah he's clearly in trouble and
actually a very very comfortable
Advantage for white in this position and
93 looks like necessary Queen D3 and
it's hard to see a counter play and
where is he going to Castle because even
castling on the queen side now it's not
really safe because of the light Square
weaknesses right and you don't want to
also Castle short as well because there
will be some G4 ideas so exactly I think
he's going to be stuck with the king in
the middle of the board exactly and I
think things are heating up in Levon and
do the game I see Pawn on G5 and H4 so
that's exciting oh definitely so we left
it kind of around
these we saw Queen takes the bishop was
on D2 Bishop went back to f8 and here we
go so Bishop E6 94 H6
oh boy oh boy I'm Not Afraid uh G5
Bishop G3 let's go Bishop F5 H4 and uh
double edge but I would say black is
risking it uh is he uh my first
impression is uh
lavon's Happy
yeah he might be happy but I think this
G5 looks dangerous but in fact uh black
is fine here because it's going to be
able to exchange couple of pieces which
is going to reduce the pressure here so
for example in this position now you can
just take only four twice it doesn't
matter how you start let's say Bishop
takes you four okay Bishop takes C4 and
now that takes away two pieces that
we're potentially trying to attack here
and next move here is to play the move
Queen E7 we know if we go to an end game
only block can be better in this
position because of the isolated pencil
level it's not going to exchange the
queen he's gonna go Queen F5 Queen F5 or
queen G4 sure in both cases you play the
move F6 and this move actually protects
G5 and also takes away the important
Knight E5 idea and if you play the move
rookie one looks like you're getting a
Tempo I just put the queen on F7 it's a
very good Square for the queen here and
now the Knight is cut off cannot go
anywhere and now rookie 8 is coming up
now to exchange the Rooks and just a few
more moves you can put in hghg and uh
Black is Black is absolutely fine it's
very hard to get to the blocking in this
position Queen G4 runs into Rook E8 if
you play rookie 6
in this position then Rook E8 comes in
and I think once once you exchange Rooks
uh it's it's absolutely fine for black
disposition wow I find myself Charmed
but you can just put your pawns on F6
and your queen on F7 be uh perfectly
safe uh just taking a quick Gander at
the game between uh and the Alan Carroll
uh with the dragon yeah but with the
Kings on opposite flanks uh the move A5
um black is kicking back quite a little
passively with Bishop E3 yes Bishop D6
that looked better right here right yeah
Bishop to D6 yeah Bishop E3 uh A5 you
start to Menace A4 okay takes takes
Knight C3 and whether or not you play it
with E4 or you put at night on D4 I
think uh the worst is passed right now
for
um Cairo we'll keep an eye on that one I
wanted to go to Anish and Wesley for a
moment because
I don't know it's uh sure feels like we
left it here
and Wesley said hey look my count of
plays against C3 what are you going to
do about it and Ani said nothing just
give it to you it's all yours let's go
A5 check and Bishop G1
and
how you like them apples bar
and just take my Pawn the engine is of
course showing zero zero but I I like
this for black I think Wesley should be
very happy with the position and in
particular I like this move H5 now he
has H5 you know it makes a lot of sense
to try to get rid of the weakness and
just try to secure that F5 Square for
the night a b so a b a b Rook B6 a b a b
and now Rook B6 you play the move Rook
G8
so you really really really want Knight
F5 yeah I want to play Knight F5 and you
probably don't want to allow that so the
move Rook B7 can be played yeah exactly
makes a lot of sense to try to pin the
Knight and now you take HG now we get
rid of our weakness and now we open up
the position of the white king as well
so now you take FG and now black can
continue with the move F5 it's it's
still equal here but you have a F5
option and also you have the move Rook
C8 as well Rook C3 ideas
so in both cases it's at the end it's
just going to be equal here but at least
you place more actively with H5 Rook G8
trying to create some threats
nice uh cool stuff
um something interesting happens in the
game of Magnus after uh 93 Knight takes
D3 He took it away F5 without waiting
for a four yes and that came at four and
suddenly this black Bishop okay
it found life in Black's pawns are fire
and H5 are pretty weak right but Bishop
on E5 is very good but there is needs to
there is an idea of 96 and 94 now
and I think Darius is telling us that
King is to go to d8 right now and black
is doing okay okay that's that's tough I
mean you you start to understand of
course that castles the desirable
castles runs into Knight takes A7 check
and Knight C6 and that is no longer
desirable you need to move your king but
you were about to tell me that H5 is
weak so you're not going long you're not
going short so you're going King d8
and castle in with just just your king
no need to look that's a hard move and
you're safe
wow if Richie finds that that uh you
gotta tip your hat and just say Well
done I mean wow I think he has to find
it otherwise you can't say desperation
the desperate moments call for desperate
uh Solutions and King d8 wow VAR Jump
Right In
would that you know be on your list wish
list
um I think just the fact that there's no
any other good moves in this position
that's the only way I think I would find
this idea I I do want to get the king
out of that pin right because it's
getting really dangerous allowing rookie
3 and possible Rook takes E5 sacrifice
so I would be really worried here
because if I play rookie 3 then you go
King date I can maybe even take only
five in that position so timing is very
important if you cancel here you're
gonna drop the H5 Pawn King on F7 is
never going to be safe because you know
open a file and it's gonna be a lot of
danger so you can go long Castle as you
mentioned you're dropping the pawn on A7
so King D is the uh only move here in
this position one thing I was trying to
understand is because after King date
for me it looks a lot of you know makes
a lot of sense to play the move Knight
D4 here sure because I want to land the
Knight on C6 over six but this position
is actually completely fine for black
after the move Bishop takes D4
eliminating the night yes I thought
white would at least be a little bit
better but looks like uh it's not a
major piece ending you think and now you
just play the move King C8 and your king
is going to be very safe on B7 and you
have enough Contra play against the G3
Pawn here
so wow there is even some lines after
Bishop D4 Rook D4 white tries to move to
play the move C5 try to land the queen
on A6 with a check but black can
actually even just take back BC in this
position both ways you can capture DC or
BC as well so let's take DC Queen A6
check now King can go to B8
and Rook D3 and you just bring your
queen to C8 to remove the queen now from
A6 so you don't have any minor pieces so
it's going to be very very difficult to
attack in this position so this is just
equal position so very important moment
here for a report he really needs to
find the move King d8 otherwise he'll be
in really big trouble here all right
thank you for that and turning to our
Lavon versus do the game you would
mention uh at this exact moment uh trade
twice on e4 play Queen E7 follow it up
with F6 and hold the position as black
and you're just doing fine dude it took
a different route he played the move
Queen E7 which at first blush looks
perfectly fine takes takes but the
bishop goes to B3 you didn't trade off
as many attackers as you have the
opportunities to a moment ago A5 on the
board I'm assuming
wow Bishop takes D5 not even waiting for
84. yeah I was about to say I assume you
play night to E5 and wait for A4 intakes
he took immediately
and positionally speaking why it should
be better yes but I think it's still a
dynamic position yeah it's quite active
so it's and it's the two I'm afraid to
ask far but I'm gonna get yeah it's
going to be triple zeros right
absolutely I don't know why we need them
every time we turn to him he goes uh
well it's triple zeros uh how is it Bart
how is the position
um it's just completely equal in fact
it's it's actually black anyone just
play the move A4 which I find it you
know a bit strange but the Palm upon A5
is hanging
uh so uh panel A5 is hanging so that's
the reason you can play the move A4 uh
another idea you have is you can also
play the move G4 which I'll be a little
bit afraid to play because it weakens
the Dark Souls but it still looks like
it's fine so let me show you after G4
here it's very concrete you attack the
Knight Knight goes only five
and now you can just play the move Rook
C8
okay
so Rook takes C8 I was about to say I
assume Bishop F4 but okay and now you
take the pawn yeah no Queen F5 comes in
and now you're interesting Queen B1 and
queen H7 bro so it's it's it's very
difficult to defend against this and uh
you know if you play Queen E1 then Queen
C2 will come in it's very active black
can also play the move F6 to remove the
knight from E5 so this will be
absolutely uh fine for black even though
down upon but let's take a look at the
Magnus this game looks like a report
played short Castle he did not find the
move King d8 well gift meeting H5 is the
best move and uh I think after Queen G7
is double attack on B2 and G3 although
you're not gonna take on YouTube if I
can play a four queen queen G7 is one of
the memberships
if you take on G3 so a lifetime
membership
and queen G7 is one of the best moves
here and here white has few options you
can play the move rookie one which is
very logical bring the Rook into the
game also you have a move Queen G5 I
like Queen G5 because you trade and then
C7 is hanging if you take on B2 I want
to take on C7
uh in that moment uh Queen takes H5
Queen G7 Queen G5
and if you take on B2 here I wanted to
take on C7 so that I had Knight E6 this
is actually just winning material yes
sir yes yes well I am
a materialist I mean in chess you have
to play Rook F7 looks like or actually
take first on G5 takes back and play
Rook F7 just to protect the C7 Pawn but
now there is a move G6 trying to deflect
this Rook from F7 and uh Rook E7 or Rook
G7 could be played and now you're gonna
lose the F5 pawn it looks like or even
Rook H Rook H6 is an option too but Rook
F1 simply attacked upon on F5
so this will be an advantage for white
as well so by the way uh get all the
games are suddenly bursting into flames
because Lavon has just played after A4
Rook C7
B5 inviting Queen C1 I it really feels
to me that and by the way clocks uh
levona has three times as much time as
much time yes today has six um
wow I mean we we've seen Duda throughout
kind of flirting with time pressure in
the number of games somehow he's always
uh you know rided the ship and he hasn't
he's undefeated but I don't know jump in
VAR Queen C1 looks awfully good for
white absolutely yeah I don't like what
Duda is doing this B5 move especially I
think it was very important to play the
move G4 and try to get the Rook on C
just try to to trade the active Rook
here so this is I did that I would have
definitely considered here right but in
a current position I think white is
doing really well he's got the full
control of the C file you no longer have
a rook C8 ideas and now you have to deal
with this Pawn hanging on G5 and after
the move Queen C1 if you place them with
Queen C1 which looks so a geometry looks
so good yeah it's it's it's hard to make
moves here now I mean one suggestion is
to play A3 which is not an easy move to
play another alternative would be to
play the move rookie 8 just
sacrificing the G5
and here's white can white can continue
with the move Rook C6 is one option
sorry ever Bishop E5 and queen takes G5
with a closing the E file sure so the
bishop E5 goes Queen G6 now he's
preparing to play F6 now if you take uh
and there's there's tactics here no way
oh wow that's beautiful and if you take
on F6 Rook
you want check King H2 and we have the
small Bishop D6 oh my gosh
Bishop E5 and actually Rook takes C5
yeah beautiful beautiful beautiful uh
variation some interesting updates uh-oh
what is it Rachel did not play Queen G7
as we were expecting okay
where's my Magnus game four to five four
five at the very bottom and we did play
Queen takes G5 Queen takes H5 pardon me
Rook E8 no Queen G7 Queen G5 checks
still no Queen G7 rook and queen H7
preparing F4 why did we play Queen H I
like this King sitting there stuck I
yeah why why aren't I playing Knight D4
check okay current position after Queen
H7
um yes
very strong first of all that is a very
serious concern secondly uh my timing
with Knight D4 is now a little bit well
I burned the advantage
uh VAR uh very
shockingly surprisingly Maggie seems to
have blown his Advantage absolutely yeah
this move Queen G5 Queen had to stay on
H5 then you can play the move Rook F1
but allowing the screen H7 I think he
just completely missed this idea and the
Queen on H7 is excellent because now F4
is very strong and it's also doing a
good job defending the C7 Pawn as well
so I think he definitely missed this
move Queen H7 and let me show you what
is the best way to play here for white
now okay so one idea is to play the move
King C2 because this F4 is coming and
your Rook is going to be hanging here so
he could actually play the smooth King
C2 just to make sure the Rook is
protected and now F4 still looks scary
F4 yeah g takes F4 Bishop FC and now
there is a move Rook G8 here trying to
get the Rook on a second Rank and here
he actually forced to sacrifice your
queen because Rook G2 you cannot allow
this move so you take only five
Rook takes G5 politics G5 you play the
move
Rook takes E5 and some some very
complicated uh lines here you have a
move like G6 looks like you're actually
holding this position with white at the
end here so G6
and rookie 2
King goes on B3 at night can go on C3
but again very very complicated position
Queen H2 Rook B1 this is one possibility
to move King C2 but he played the move
Queen D2 this is another option here and
I think report is going to play the move
F4 in this position to open up the
diagonal
and attack The Rook you know it's funny
when I see these Kings indeed in defense
players and oftentimes they're looking
for dynamic play uh for Pawn weaknesses
or for uh uh upon down and if you look
at blacks
Harmony of the two Rooks the bishop on
E5 Queen on H7 is very very clear that
black has a good compensation by E5
looks uh tremendous Queen D2 King C7
that would have been fun
yeah sorry that would have been fun
Queen B2 can block just buy F4 right now
and on G takes F take Rook F4 yeah I was
about to say I mean your queen is not
ready to capture on uh F4
and so uh
couldn't do I thought you were going to
play Queen D1 just to get to cover the
first rank well I was doing it I was I
was trying to get you to blockade your
Rook you know you know uh maybe I was
being a little bit too flippant but yeah
okay Queen D1
and by the way I have four on the board
as expected maybe Rook E4 here
yeah yeah I don't like it I don't like
your posting up I don't like Knight A3
um the night on B5 needs to come back
about where when how yeah exactly you
also have a move rookie 3 there which
could be really awesome yeah forcing the
move King C2 exactly and then call Queen
E4 and looks like white escapes with a
Perpetual there with Queen H5 Queen G4
you know what I would be delighted to
escape my Perpetual at this point uh
nice
um f4 on the board uh VAR is uh
I mean I I feel like I have to be
accurate now as white if I slip up
um and again the times of these two
players he has an alternative guys if
Magnus really wants to play for a win he
knows probably by now if he takes on F4
he's not going to win the game right so
if he wants to play for a win he has to
take a big risk here and play the move
G4
allowing that pawn remainder on F4 and
again for now he needs a couple of moves
to just consolidate his position but uh
we can take a look after G4 what could
happen here okay so G4
and uh black has a few options here A6
move is suggested just try to remove the
knight from B5 another move is to play
the move F3 immediately
let's look at F3 now you need the smooth
Queen C2 because the spin is just
getting too strong here you need to play
this move and now you're already
threatening to take the pawn on F3
okay so black can play the move F2 looks
larger there are there are other options
as well and now you have to find the
only move here for white which is Rook
E3
wow so you're inviting Bishop G3 yes
Rook but you have Bishop G3 here
so I'm trying to land on E1 with a chat
Queen takes H7 yeah can you take the H7
and you cannot allow The Rook come to
the e-file so you need to block it with
the move rookie 6 here
oh my word this looks so winning for the
black I know that pawn on F2 is so uh
Bishop takes H4 and you bring the king
into the game King C2 and looks like
somehow white is holding but again yeah
this is this is risky wow uh I would
have I I'm not tempted by this but your
G4 if Magnus plays G4 my goodness his uh
desire to win is insatiable I hear that
Levon has blown his advantage and it's
really pretty equal now at that when we
left it we had expected Queen C1 did he
play yes he did and he did play A3 takes
takes but LeBron shouldn't have
exchanged Queens
should have played Queen D2 instead of
Queen G5 oh come on come on come on keep
the queen he would have lost his
membership in the pond Grabbers
Association he should play Queen D2 and
just keep the Queens on the board yes
because Black's kingsitis
forever weekend right
bro but come on I mean I don't blame him
one bit hey Queen takes G5 F6
Knight had to go to H7 I kind of would
I don't know can I I don't know 987
Bishop f8 Knight F7 and then yes pardon
me Knight F7 yeah blush Bishops are
controlling all the squares around the
yeah and wow yeah I I could play Bishop
here but then I'm getting into a bishops
of opposite color and I don't believe my
winning chances are that great wow uh so
he blew it with Queen takes G5
absolutely just winning a palm but
exchanging the Quince it was more
important to play the move Queen D2 and
to keep the Queens on the board and a
lot of attacking chances here Bishop E5
is very strong then you want to capture
back uh with a knight on G5 right
well I always say uh you know those
Queen trades I think of it as a
Marketplace and when should we trade
Queens we should trade Queens when our
King is weak
we want to trade Queens when our King is
weak when our opponents King is weak as
is the current situation we don't want
to trade Queens even even when we're
winning upon remarkable let me get
caught up with the play for just a
moment because we do have Bishop to D6
and you know I'm thinking I'm a pawn up
but uh it's it's not enough far
uh Bishop D6 will actually now Rook
takes A2 and uh black is just winning
the pawn back and Bishop takes f8 is it
that simple
96. I think Bishop
537 look up six
yes but then in that case it's very
risky to be Pawn is going to be very
quick b-pawn versus the two connected
pawns on the king side but b-pawn is
much faster and it's supported by a rook
and a and we have this on the board but
yeah he did take the F1 he said that
that deep on is fast yeah I remember
Michael Tall saying you know two
connected fast pawns versus one the two
connected past bonds are slower yes
let's just move this set up 98. I think
we're gonna see probably a draw soon
Rook A4 Rook A4 yeah if Knight takes B5
exchange and just take on D4 okay
so blood cannot keep the B point if he
tries to play Rook B2 then 988
and I'm losing a different Pawn Yeah
getting from here
wow
um by the way that's just the quick
update on mvo again we're talking about
the primary squares for the knights F6
and C6 look at this white got his Knight
to F6 when we left it we were back here
we thought okay blacks the worst was
behind him
but mvl got his Knight
secured on F6 yes one of your favorite
squares for the night primary squares
you're absolutely absolutely
yeah it looks very promising for him
yeah I like him
um I just did play G4 the risky move wow
wow and not only that but against F3 he
played A3 thinking he's got all the Time
in the World to play King A2 and get his
King off this pin
wow that's that just strikes me as so
risky it's remarkable now A6 is very
strong
because
the desirable Knight D4 Bishop takes D4
you can't
Knight C3 only move in fact engine
thinks you should take on C7
and just give up the piece but you
capture on F3 after I think white wants
to do that okay but just to exploit this
I guess it's Bishop F4 Bishop F4 and
actually sorry F2 first F2 first
wow and now you're threatening the move
Rook F3
oh and by the way A6 Knight C3 very
quickly on the board Richie has to find
F2 F2 very important threatening uh
continue while you're saying yeah two
yeah King A2 is the is forced he played
Rook F4 he played Rook F4 and it still
looks pretty good yeah and then Bishop
F4 is just to finish up this line Bishop
goes on F4 attacking the queen after
King A2 and uh
Queen C2 you play the move Rook E3
this looks really nice really two
exchanging the Queens
and then you play the move Bishop G3
with the idea of rookie one it's a very
very big Advantage for black almost
winning but now after the move Rook F4
yeah uh evaluation dropped significantly
here and uh
and we look like we're gonna have a draw
between Daniel and radislav here Rook F4
King A2 on the board uh in the game of
Magnus and
yeah now I think anything can happen
here Magnus has
can she they're playing opposite color
bishop and game so be a quick draw
rattleslav did not have a good day today
he started by beating Magnus in the
first round today day one two losses
and there was a big blunder in the last
game against the Nish pain yes that was
at the very end
literally
losing the game on one one move that
that really hurts
and here they're just looking for a
repetition I I'm guessing well it seemed
like they had one and then they didn't
finally there we go
one minute to 13 let me see
dear keeps playing remarkable I don't
understand why why is he keeps playing
okay well this game uh yeah
handshake uh King A2 was played oh let's
catch up by the way A6 Knight C3 Rook F4
not the not F2 Richie missed an
opportunity Rook F4 King A2 getting
ready to give me the pawn Rook takes C
Rook takes F3 Rook f8 Rook F2 don't want
to see upon F2 go ahead and grab here so
I can grab here not interested says
Richie
and finally a handshake and a draw on
that game will stay with Maggie magnus's
game for a moment a G5 Queen H5 Queen D1
uh it's a bit of a tangled mess Magna
was catching up on time because he had a
lot more time earlier okay now Richard
has four minutes and Magnus has six
minutes so
not a big difference uh still
um
uh
very difficult position to play yeah and
for me white has a coordination problem
the Knight on C3 is just a bad piece uh
I I need that night to be literally on
any other square is E6 would be nice C6
would be nice E3 E1 was his last name of
Queen G4 I think he wants to play Bishop
D4 right yes so he can advance farther
yes uh one problem you might allow me to
sacrifice in exchange
Bishop D4 Rook F3 and by the way uh
leaders have drawn
had a chance but
it wasn't easy to find the queen detune
and somehow do the a he's
well undefeated undefeated remains in
the lid and remains Elite but again you
know the slippage there's cracks in his
armor but he's not being punished
um Queen G4 of our Jump Right In uh
I like this you know creepy crawly
little moves but it keeps the pressure
on Magnus yeah well here's um H5 is an
interesting idea just to sacrifice the
pawn and if you take on G5 then finally
you can take on F3 because you really
want to eliminate that pawn here oh no
question so Queen takes H5 it looks like
you're still keeping it and now a strong
move Knight B1 with the idea to play
Knight D2 and finally get rid of the
Pawn on so why why did we throw the pawn
away
exactly let me ask uh the question for
Nazi why do why do we need uh H5 and not
Knight B1 at once if you play Knight B1
at once I have a move Bishop D4 okay
tickling
and I say so if Queen's not on the
fourth rank there is no Bishop you don't
have Bishop before there because you can
take Rook takes D4 gotcha
and by the way if I play H5 and you play
Bishop D4 then I can do that exchange
sacrifice
and uh I'll take on H5 I would be happy
here with black
probably
and by the way we do have Knight B1 by
Magnus immediately without the inclusion
of the move H5 so he is inviting Bishop
D4 and is that an invitation and you
can't resist or I think yeah he's he's
going to be sacrificing an exchange now
after Rook F2 takes F3 yeah Rook takes
F3 Rook takes default exactly and this
is what he wants to do looks like black
is slightly better there
and
you can play Rook 8 to F4 just
exchanging this Rook because you want to
have some pressure against the C4 Pawn
here and agreed Rook takes
F4
and you if you take with the queen then
there is a nice move Knight D2 attacking
the rook and also you're getting the
queen out to H5 so you probably want to
take back with the rook and definitely
white doesn't want to trade Quincy the
end game would be last year and uh are
we sure about that by the way well
because I think uh because the question
is is can I get to Black's Queen side
by the way mvl won a nice game wow sorry
too our MBL fans that we didn't pay
enough attention to it but we saw the
night on F6 we saw that KIRO by the way
Carol had a bad day yeah
Magnus and he just lost to MBL
um you you were about to tell me that
this ending after King B3 uh we have
some moves so Richard didn't play Bishop
D4 he played Queen G3 first
uh sorry right here after 91. I got the
wrong position sorry Knight B1 bg3
Magnus played Rook F1 quickly still on
his agenda is Knight D2
he wants to take this pawn and it's
pinned
it's black
continue because we can push F2 we don't
have Bishop D4 anymore Queen G2 is his
Richie's idea the best one was to go
back actually Queen G4 that's the best
yeah because against Knight D2 you want
to be able to play the move F2
and your queen is defended here queen
queen G2 which is
kind of like The Logical follow-up to
his previous play now whether the queen
is good on G2 they're a different matter
I'm assuming 92.92 will be played
and you have to play F2 no F2 allows
Queen H5
I don't think Richard wants to do that
Queen H5 and losing because I get G6
wow I thought it was Perpetual what a
shock oh that would be it and guess gift
Guess Who Came To Dinner yeah
Queen wow okay so Knight to D2 and boy I
thought Richard was just reaching you
can't play King G7 here for black to
make sure that Queen H5 doesn't come
with a Tempo oh and F3 is not hanging
yet because of B2 yeah and uh yeah
there's a maid on B2 at the end of the
line
how crafty there is a me King G7 give me
the pawn I'm so eager to take it and any
trades and oops that is nice and also
very important because in that line you
could have taken with the queen and
after Queen the two maybe force a draw
with Queen f8 check right but here you
don't have that anymore so for example
A5 this is uh just to vars point that
uh I do get a Perpetual check in this
case so that's why the king should go to
G7 right here right now and now I think
white can maybe just play Rook G1 and
just try to
just just harass the queen queen H2 Rook
H1 again
and anytime you go to the third I come
back
in order to attack this pawn and what's
the evaluation here
after King G7 we're anticipating the
best move King G7 it's our favorite guys
I mean our least favorite our least
favorite
um
yeah apparently it's triple zeros triple
zeros and three minute extra time for
Magnus I think Richie maybe should
figure out a way to just simplify the
position because he has four one of the
things that I tell you uh Richie's fans
adore about him I mean even when he has
no time on the clock he's not looking
for a Perpetual check he is looking to
win the game his uh his thrill seeking
uh here we go Bishop G7
um he's he's suggesting there's no
captures on F3
Bishop but there is seven captures on F3
and I can take Queen F3 Queen D2 and
then they've got the perfect pet right
I've got a Perpetual check so Magnus can
bail out with Rook takes F3 and make a
Perpetual check against the black king
at the cost but he should he should not
maybe just push H5
your opponent doesn't have that much
time and uh just to see how Richie is
going to respond against this just
because if he takes on G5 now then he
has time to capture the pawn on F3 and
what if blood pushes F2 after H5
the the one idea with F2 once you played
you don't you no longer have that Queen
B2 threat anymore so after F2 G6 is a
move
I was I was thinking you for sure
playing H6 and chasing the bishop back
to E5 but G6 okay
and uh
it looks like black can even just play
now Bishop E5 it's it's hard to make
progress for either side here I know the
rookie eight instead and I think I'm
making some progress
Rook E8 wishful thinking here hoping to
go rookie one and look I mean it drives
on the board uh Magnus says I'd like to
play for the win as well as you Queen
takes G5 let me just refresh my board
everybody uh don't get angry with me
Queen takes G5 inviting Rook takes F3
isn't this a dream moment for Magnus
that he can at last eliminate this Pawn
um yeah he can also take Knight takes F3
here
allowing the pin yeah I think the pin is
okay Knight takes F3 so you will play
Queen G2 or
okay Queen G2 does and now there is Rook
d2 move okay
Queen G
3 and then without the engines Rook df2
Knight F3 it's so hard to play uh I I
would after Queen takes G5 I'd want to
trade a pair of Rooks
so you would take with which Rook after
Queen G5 let's say Rook on F1 takes F3
if you go Queen takes H5 I've got a
nasty surprise but then it's just uh we
just trade everything right and I take
on H5 and
Rook takes F3
um yes Knight takes F3 Queen H5
isn't that a relief and is it Black's
King a little bit more vulnerable than
White's King I don't know Queen E2
there is still some pressure look at
four now this C4 Pawn is still hanging
wow so it looks like some kind of a
repetition after
Queen G2 Rook G4 wow this is just one
possible and most likely this is not
gonna happen because I think both
players are trying to play for a win and
they are
so
apparently the best line for white here
is to take with the Knight
and then go Rook B3
just defending the Nate on B2
saying do your worst and we'll say now
if my mistakes with the Knight or The
Rook one of the things that makes Magnus
so remarkable is his Precision in
certain endings is just uh well off the
charts uh maybe have 40 seconds by the
way
maybe one of the most precise if not the
most precise world champions ever Magnus
Carlson and he has played into this
ending
um
VAR said maybe black has some pressure
and I I was thinking that it was Black's
King that was more vulnerable he's
played Queen
getting out of the pin now this Knight
is just searching for a home you know
Knight D4 so you can Menace Rook H3 Rook
F4 okay I've got Knight D2 blood king
can just hide on G8 and
looks safe on jeans that Bishop is
defending everything around it I wow
okay I
I was thinking Black's King
if you could teleport it to B7 you've
got a fan but you're on h8 you're not
Crossing all the files are you you
played rookies
um
let's move
kind of a Prelude again I'm looking for
a way of improving my Knight's position
but I really do think that both players
are playing for a win no question no
question I'm just objectively speaking
what's the truth for
I think it's it's still around equal but
I think uh I see maybe some chances here
for Magnus me too
I'm thinking Knight E1 if I can get my
if I can get my it all depends if I can
get my knight to a good Square good
squares are E4 good squares or E6 C6 and
it's just 14 seconds on the clock he's
he's just played the move Queen D3 Rook
attacks Pawn right now six seconds
finally got into a good Square it's it's
decent oh now I'm waiting for black
right okay Rook H3 is a killer threat so
Rook to G3 Queen E4 okay give me The
Rook
oh this is looking dangerous G2 is
hanging
part the G2 is hanging yes yes pardon me
yes so Richie is getting a little bit
scary right
yeah Queen H2 Knight coming in now on
the king side can I go Queen H2 only
move okay Queen G4
Magnus Magnus sensing opportunity white
can win a pot Queen g496 yes that's the
best and just winning this is seven
points G2 I have oh he didn't do it he
goes Check
he's looking at Rook E4
wow okay this is super tense what's the
time what's the time control what's 20
seconds 20 seconds yes man I'm I'm
looking at the player's nervous hands
and I'm like okay I can really picture
myself here and going oh oh oh Richie
five seconds Richie Richie's looking at
Queen H Rook H4 is a killer move but the
Knight can't move
B2 is hanging
Queen D7 pinning the bishop oh wait
there's
oh never mind
I thought that was working too but I
don't think so now Rook takes B2 will
force a draw Rook name two and queen D2
check Queen D2 well he played Rook H2
can I play King B3 maybe roof should
should my king go for a run
Rook E7
does Rook B2 still work
is Rook B2 still a draw
I I just heard that you say that B5 is
the force and movement four seconds four
seconds and D5 is hanging we can't move
the Knight B2 is hanging that would be
Checkmate amazing fine B5 wow
All the nervousness Queen C7 Queen C7
and
and he's gone for the Perpetual chat yes
now we'll have a draw wow
uh Queen D3 check King A2 it's time
what's the clock times uh 20 seconds
again they gain some time with the last
few moves
boy they're warming up for the blitz
tomorrow what a finish that's an
incredible game I I was holding my
breath
and just as we were uh Wesley and Anish
Gary did draw there they draw
this game had it all I mean
come on Magnus what are you thinking
about here you King A2 yeah
he's testing Richard but well there's no
way to oh he's walked into Queen takes
D4 check
uh
what
that okay well there's King C2 there's
no one but what if just Queen D2
what if this queen D2 sorry I I thought
white was trying to avoid Queen takes D4
check
yeah Rich is like no I'll just take a
draw
and they're laughing all right those
players a great sense of relief
great sense that was amazing that
Richard played with three seconds on the
clock
I think they played a couple of moves
there we're just uh seconds whoa
um
the crazy part was uh both players were
walking on a tightrope but
the valuation never really fluctuated
greatly am I right at one point yes sir
at one point move number 47 he should
have he should have exchanged coins and
lend that Knight to that E6 Square then
he would he would get an end game with
extra pawn and good winning chances
there that was the only moment where he
had chances this was the this was the
moment where Magnus played check here he
could have taken Knight E6 distracted
The Rook from B2 1986.
that's a great idea
and if you have to play Rook here then
Rook to B3 and this is so the best movie
there is Bishop E5 okay uh no if we go
back sorry just Bishop E5 after 96
and then Knight takes C7 Rook takes C4
Knight H6 and this is a technical end
game where I think you know white has
markers would have loved it you know
white has decent chances to win for sure
yeah yeah no this is uh definitely
Maggie's uh kind of game but what a day
we've had and our current leader Duda I
mean to tip your head he started with
two wins as we saw on his line score and
he asked a clear lead and he won this
tournament last year guys yeah he's the
defending Champion dude is doing great
and closely following livon aroni and
just one point behind and Wesley so and
Maxi Michelle Agra thanks to mbl's
Victory yes sir yeah sure third Maggie
been catching up Magnus in the fifth
place at the moment didn't do the
trifecta didn't do the sweet but he was
really close Richie hangers with nine
points and then
our schedule we have two Blitz days
coming up yeah 39 rounds of Blitz nine
points up for grabs
um anything can happen
and let's jump to uh Warsaw as Christian
is with Magnus
Magnus a good day at the office could
have been a great day at the office
emotions are high right now sum it up
for us
um
obviously first two games were good for
me
um
finally got some uh well finally got
some some chances but yeah last game was
just it was just a mess up to a certain
point I think I did everything pretty
well uh but then I missed one key idea
and after that it was just a mess I mean
I was probably
uh lost and then probably winning and
then you know probably last I don't know
let's actually have a look at it because
I have no idea it was super interesting
yeah so I think everything was sort of
preceding pretty nicely up to a certain
point here Bishop Basics was trying to
provoke me but I wouldn't let myself be
provoked I kind of wanted to go Knight
G5 and F4 for instance I was thinking of
King f8 then exactly I can go Knight G5
and if it takes twice like before before
catching the um oh that's nice catching
the knights yeah I can just do it really
quickly and then before yep and it's not
a surprise when he's put he's
weird squares that it's uh that is that
is bad but it's nevertheless nice and
once I get Knight G5 and F4 then she's
in a lot your attack is coming yeah yeah
so she yeah so we did
um there's quite logically
uh F5
uh it doesn't have to go go F5 but then
what uh yeah he doesn't really have a
good place to hide the king like if he
goes on the king side he's king
um his uh light squares are really weak
or I would like to call them the dark
squares because to me it looks like some
kind of some kind of French where black
is stuck with this terrible Bishop on D7
and black has already played G6 you know
and then reverse fresh yeah it's a
reverse basically
um so yeah four
um this is probably not first but it was
extremely attempting
wow King the eight yeah
that's brilliant and pretty much the
only move oh that's really that's super
nice
I didn't see that I wouldn't trust this
engine too much
yeah but I I can see the point like he
cannot Castle either side without losing
a pawn and you cannot let the Knight
come to D4 damn we didn't think about it
oh that would have been brilliant okay
um he did not yeah he did not do that
okay let's say castle it was surprised
he didn't go
quenches seven
um I mean that seemed like
pretty much didn't only move to me
um
but
yeah I mean just look at one here and he
can practically resign uh Queen G7 I can
just
Oh I thought I could take the pawn
um but yeah I mean just fine as well
yeah just the book F3 just yeah the pawn
just Falls and you get the G5 yeah it's
it's it's basically game over
um yeah E6 I just go back
so uh but I thought I'd be even more
clever uh and prevent Queen
and prevent Queen G7 and then like often
times when you make a mistake like this
you notice it immediately I didn't
notice it until he put the screen on H7
was it like a culture that was a cold
shower like I realized that
yeah I have no
uh no semblance of an advantage anymore
so here I mean and also the position is
much easier to play for but in order to
try you have to take some serious yeah
G4 like
I I thought GF was uh pretty dryish so I
didn't or I mean he he really has the
fun there I'm the one who has to has to
make some good moves so I thought here
as long as it doesn't lose immediately
um yeah and apparently a three is really
bad yeah my first instinct was to go for
this as well but
and then there's I think there was ah
yeah Bishop I saw this but I didn't
think I could win such a position
but but yeah this is this is crazy I
mean A3
I think there was only one six F2 uh in
this position
uh if yeah F2 I was thinking Knight D1
I miss book history
yeah I actually because I sucking it to
Bishop for his game over
um
yeah but guys both were you know like
three minutes at this point yes no I had
more I had a bit more oh you had seven
minutes several minutes
I was just playing Portland okay so here
might be one
okay so this was like at least half
reasonable Bishop G7 was a surprise
um
okay
anyway here I was like slightly
optimistic
and hoping that he's King was somehow
weaker than mine and at least a little
quick trick of Queen to fortnite D4
which is rubbish according to the
engines
um but I can probably go like this and
Bishop B5 oh what am I talking about
rubikita oh that's not protected yeah
okay so that's nonsense that was
nonsense so okay so I
that was that was not even close Okay I
was slipping away at this yeah he was
slipping a little bit so Queenie for
this I was happy to see
oh I could take a 96 was 96. okay what's
the what's rookie two I got Rook b3m
this punches full
yeah I didn't I didn't even see that now
the question is what if he just stays
here what if he just goes king of seven
Okay so he went for this
and B5 B yeah it was amazing
it was an amazing move yeah this is
really nice yeah B5 was was a good fight
and after
this yeah it was kind of uh can you
explain the point of uh B5 I don't think
we yeah
he just wants to
um Cage My Kingdom Union so for instance
here Rook B2 would not work because I
just go up the board King B4 and here I
hide
so B5 takes away the the f
aith yep so um
um yeah this is um so actually actually
we played well yeah that was surprising
very decent game that was surprising but
um yeah exciting for exciting for sure
well tomorrow the blitz starts you
talked about variance variance is
getting higher in the blitz action are
you going to uh take your chances even
more with the openings how are you going
to approach the blitz portion uh we'll
see so I I guess do that is pretty far
ahead three points uh three points but
the others are not yes so
um
you are like four points behind three
players yeah it really depends on it
depends on dude like he's really
it's really strong so if he has a great
event then I don't have a chance uh
probably uh but if he doesn't anyone can
can win so I'm I'm happy I've at least
given myself
um a chance
um I was actually you know I was playing
some Blitz online yesterday and I some
secret account or no no I'm on an open
account but
I just wanted to win a few chess games
you know and then after I won those I
was thinking ah I can actually still
play chess I'm I'm fine yeah so I was
more emotivated for today still 18 games
to go plenty of opportunities to win
games we'll see you tomorrow Magnus
thank you guys back to you thank you
Christian and thank you Magnus and this
is how his tournament is unfurled uh bad
start starting with a loss then a lot of
trust but today what a great day right
it can turn around and wind in his sails
as the rapid comes to a close and the
blitz begins 18 points of Blitz a dead
ahead but there is one Jan Duda that uh
stealing the show yes he's been
dominating so far and he's in the clear
lead right now with 13 points three
points clear of Magnus one point clear
of Lavon and two points clearer from
Wesley and MBO Richard on the outside
didn't help his uh
tournament today but Anish kind of
bounced a little bit he's feeling it but
really it's those top guys that are
fighting for the podium of our
absolutely I think the top five guys one
of them is going to be the winner of
this tournament and again yeah do that
continuous play really well it's going
to be hard to catch him but otherwise I
think everybody has a shot exactly and
let's jump back to Warsaw as Christian
is with our leader
you're stealing the show in front of
your own fans sum up your feelings after
day three yeah I'm very happy because
I mean first the rapid stage is over
because I'm always you know working on
playing beats and secondly you know that
um I think I have played um yeah quite
quite some
quite a good stress and
um
yeah of course some games were you know
not that great but um our overall it's
like possible it's very good result
especially today against the mvl take us
through this game because this was
a masterpiece and we were discussing
about this a little bit with Gary you
mentioned to him he said that you had
some preparation in this line after the
game against Anish in Bucharest you
Unleashed that preparation today
I mean okay it's a draw yeah but um of
course but um yeah I had it in like uh
already in January 2022 I got the file
about this like but I uh of course when
I play Daniel so I I uh like I hadn't
expected it and uh it was you know
difficult to memorize I like to recall
what I had in the notes so I so I played
it safe this time I decided to play into
vary and to play Rook A4 which is area
uh I mean I see foreign
and here this is critical line probably
kind of false and
okay he's doing sacrifice yeah here I uh
I I
like I expected Knight H5 to be played
uh this is like very a very strange line
yeah like this
for short one
um
and here there are like um
many moves I want to play I think okay
four here I mean it's just some Gloria
but then some crazy yeah here for
example I think they're like yeah H6 and
G5 are okay but H5 is not you know it's
like a very uh if it's the position I I
wanted them but uh 97 is um sorry on
this one uh yeah here yeah uh no I
thought science slightly better actually
uh here this bishop D4 is very
sophisticated move yeah I mean Castle
looks more natural but I'm
well they kind of yeah Knight B6 was the
move
I still think that yeah take Stakes
Bishop default is for choice right yes
um yeah but it's like you know in the
game and
um
and I Photoshopped it for you know it's
like Ultra accurate because the balance
is really protected so that I can find
any free okay that makes sense keep more
pieces on the board yeah yeah and here
okay I mean Knight C5 could have uh also
been played there but um
should be two
and um Knight A6
will be four like
um it seems like you're the one having
fun yeah yeah and black is probably
looking for some Perpetual along the way
along the lines I mean and here I I
think it's like very very nice position
for white because I'm
um I'm ultra solid and I will
consolidate and start emerging my c-pawn
yeah and
it's like very difficult I think to
oppose this one
and
um yeah here also like Bishop 193 is
very natural I mean maybe some E5 also
96 was the idea but okay I thought it's
very very reasonable and yeah and here
when you feel like you're uh yeah I'm no
I I mean Bishop takes D5 was very weird
uh
yeah to be honest I don't get it like
um I I mean I would have never done it
with black so
um yeah but maybe
yeah
yeah it's just yeah it's extremely
unpleasant and here of course the point
is
um Dr quintix d500 is Mission free check
of course yeah and then we show before
okay yeah maybe this is what he uh F5
rugby after 95 he must have seen it yeah
yeah so uh yeah but it was very strange
actually yeah because this position
looks kind of hopeless in the wrong
round for him because I'm not sure you
ever Consolidated like place my Rooks on
I don't know C1 D1 yeah and uh step back
we might be shopping then yeah so and
here I mean okay was very unexpected of
the final mistake yeah I I mean yeah and
here it was I was very surprised yeah
because um I could have played like
everything I was actually wondering if
uh
yeah so I mean I can do whatever I want
but um H3 you know like D6 I also for
this interesting guys after H3 I can
just you know ignore or even take and
because my Bishop is getting active yeah
so I was I spent like I don't know five
minutes on the small H3 and humidity
design
some checkmates well last year you won
it you are the defending Champion but
after a rapid portion you were actually
in the third position right now you have
I think a two-point lead or like a one
point lead over the one three points
over Magnus sitting pretty so definitely
um improved on your result a lot of
games still uh to be played but as you
mentioned you do prefer blitz so we're
looking forward to see you tomorrow yeah
guys back to you thank you Christian and
thank you dude indeed some real Blitz
Specialists mvl do that
Lavon Magnus uh we've got a jam-packed
uh Blitz session coming up for you
tomorrow and the next day but sum it up
for us for this was quite nice uh these
three days of Blitz three days of Rapids
pardon me uh I enjoyed every one of them
yeah me too it was very very exciting
it's nice to see Magnus play well and
now he's in the mix as well and Duda has
been very impressive Levon as well so I
think we're gonna see some really
interesting games and a lot of blunders
perhaps with the police time control but
a lot of players still can win this
tournament so she'll be very very
exciting two days of Blitz coming up
guys the best players in the world in
their best form uh could be fun uh oh I
might as well pass this graph
wow uh you ladies are doing great
yeah
um I'm languishing I have no
explanations for Anisha Anish has no
explanations for enemies but uh really
really nice it was a fun day yes and I'm
expecting more decisive games in the
blitz yeah yeah absolutely
one one last word uh the view from
Warsaw
well you guys are looking uh pretty in
your predictions but I'm warming up as
well my prediction is had a good date
when a half out of three I'll take that
for sure and with 18 games to go still
this is anybody's tournament I have to
say I'm very excited to see what these
players are going to bring to the tables
and how this tournament is going to
unfold because up to this point so much
excitement see here in Warsaw and
Anastasia tell us about your journey
what did you do uh today you took a lot
of interviews you talked to the players
as well tell us about your day yeah I
was also talking to the public and there
are so many chess fans and all of them
shared some thoughts emotions and
actually I just came from this fan Zone
I was running here to the studio because
you know Magnus Carlson was just came
there and like hundreds of people were
literally like jumped on him and you
know at this moment I need security said
okay this is the best moment now to
escape but here it was just you know
trying to you know go next and then
finally he managed to get it out from
the you know because the old crowd was
concentrated on Magnus so he did yeah so
you see how smart what a smart idea you
had so yeah it was great event I was
following also the games and the players
were also chatting in the player's room
and the atmosphere was great Gary also
came there and they discussed the game
with kyriel and the other players also
you know guys were discussing Sharjah
Masters tournament between the games
they were checking they went in Sharjah
and also discussing some of them so it
was a nice day you know full of emotions
and yeah I mean looking forward to Blitz
tomorrow well the action is getting
faster and more Furious tomorrow and I
cannot wait to see all those species
flying around here Warsaw Poland guys
back to you thank you Anastasia thank
you Christian indeed we've seen three
great days of Rapid we have two
and when the players are in good form
and it just seems like our top five
leaderboard uh they're they're going to
be in good form we're going to have a
very exciting uh race to the Finish I
can't wait very exciting thank you for
sharing your day with us we'll look
forward to sharing it tomorrow we'll see
you all tomorrow join us tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited